I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, everyone. Ho, ho, ho. This is a big episode. It's the Christmas episode. It's the Christmas episode. The very first Christmas episode of The Office. Season two, episode 10. You know, it's not, we call it the Christmas episode. Yeah,
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在做《办公室》的终极重温播客，只为你。每周我们将解析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。大家好。哦，哦，哦。这一集很大。这是圣诞节那一集。这是圣诞节那一集。非常特别的《办公室》第一集圣诞节。第二季，第10集。你知道，这不是，我们称之为圣诞节那一集。是的，
we do. Or Christmas episode. But it is technically called Christmas party. What? Yeah, that's the name of this episode. Christmas party. I don't believe you. I don't believe you. No, I'm kidding. We did. We call it the Christmas episode. We call it the Christmas episode. Yeah. Even though there were many more, this is the Christmas episode. I have so much to say. I have 12 typed pages today. It looks like you're holding like a mini phone book. I feel like I'm holding a one-act play or something. It's very large. And when I came in today, I will share that I refuse to speak to anyone because I said I was saving it for the mic. And I'm saving it
我们这么叫。或者叫圣诞节那一集。但它在技术上被称为圣诞派对。什么？是的，这就是这一集的名称。圣诞派对。我不相信你。我不相信你。不，开玩笑的。我们确实这么叫。我们称之为圣诞节那一集。我们称之为圣诞节那一集。是的。尽管后来还有更多，但这就是圣诞节那一集。我有太多话要说。我今天有12页打印稿。你看上去像是拿着一本迷你电话本。我觉得我拿着一幕剧本什么的。非常厚。而且我今天进来的时候，我要分享一下我拒绝和任何人说话，因为我说我要把它留给麦克风。我要把它
for the mic. She did. I tried to make a spell. Let's talk with her. And she's like, I'm saving it for the mic. I was like, okay, lady, you do you. I just, I just gonna tell you, I liked your hair. I, you got little pigtails today and they're real cute. I have plats. What are plats? That's what they say in the UK. They're like, oh, look at your plats. Oh, yeah. They also call bangs fringe. I know. I like it. Yeah. I don't know if you notice my side of the table. Totally filled with note cards by my side of the table. You guys, I've made a buffet of note cards. Like, I actually have to be aware, like Sam is saying to stay in front of the
留给麦克风。她真的这么做了。我试图跟她打招呼。跟她聊聊。她说，我要把它留给麦克风。我说，好吧，女士，你随意吧。我只想告诉你，我喜欢你的头发。我有小辫子。什么是小辫子？英国那边就是这么说的。他们会说，哦，看你的小辫子。哦，是的。他们还把刘海叫作fringe。我知道。我喜欢。是的。不知道你有没有注意到我桌子的这一边。桌子的这一边完全摆满了便签卡。你们知道吗，我做了一个便签卡的自助餐。实际上我必须注意，就像山姆说的，要呆在
microphone because I have so many cards. I keep, I'm gonna have to slide back and forth. Yeah. Down my buffet of cards. You love a buffet. I love a buffet, baby. Even a fifth note card. Give me that Vegas buffet. All right, Christmas party written by Mike Shore and directed by Charles McDougal. Here's a synopsis. It's Christmas at Dunder Mifflin. Today is the day of the office holiday party. The group originally plans to have a secret Santa gift exchange, but when Michael doesn't like his gift, he turns it into a Yankee swap. This causes a multitude of confusion and hurt feelings and Michael's solution is then to go out and buy booze,
麦克风前面，因为我有太多的卡片。我得来回移动。是的。沿着我的卡片自助餐。你喜欢自助餐。我喜欢自助餐，宝贝。哪怕是第五张便签卡。把那个拉斯维加斯自助餐给我。好的，由迈克·肖尔编剧、查尔斯·麦克道格尔执导的圣诞派对。剧情梗概如下。邓德米夫林迎来了圣诞节。今天是办公室假日派对的日子。大家原本计划进行一次秘密圣诞老人礼物交换，但当迈克尔不喜欢他的礼物时，他将其变成了洋基换物。这导致了大量的混乱和受伤的感情，而迈克尔的解决方案是出去买酒，
which is against company rules and to try to get the party back on track. 15 bottles of vodka. That'll do it. Fastback number one. As I've already said, it's our very first Christmas episode, but we filmed it nowhere near Christmas. No, you never do because you have to stay ahead. So you're always, it's like Christmas in July kind of thing. Well, we had a fan question from Sarah McGreen, did US cast members ever have Christmas parties or do a Yankee swap? And if so, what was the best funniest gift someone brought? A lot of people also asked if we exchanged gifts as a cast. Not at the holidays. We would do what's called a
这违反了公司规定，并试图让派对重回正轨。15瓶伏特加。这招管用。幕后花絮一。正如我已经说过的，这是我们的第一集圣诞节，但我们拍摄它的时间离圣诞节十万八千里。不，你从来不会在圣诞节拍，因为你必须保持进度超前。所以你总是在做七月圣诞节那种事。好吧，我们有一个来自萨拉·麦格林的粉丝提问，美国演员们有没有办过圣诞派对或玩过洋基换物？如果有，大家带过的最好、最搞笑的礼物是什么？很多人还问我们演员之间是否交换礼物。假期不交换。我们会做所谓的杀青礼物，
wrap gift, which happens at the end of the season. And we would usually finish filming our seasons in like, what, April? And then the cast would get together and we'd pull our money and we would buy the crew. Every member of the crew would get a gift from the cast. And then sometimes cast members would give each other wrap gifts. Little individual gifts. Yeah. I did host a Yankee swap Christmas party and I did it every year for a few years. And I actually want to bring it back. I took a few years off because just, you know, life kids and, you know, stuff like that. Yeah. But I hosted a Yankee swap party every year. And oh, yes, you did. And it
这发生在季末。我们通常在差不多四月份结束拍摄？然后演员们会聚在一起，凑钱给剧组买礼物。剧组的每位成员都会收到来自演员的礼物。有时候演员们也会互相送杀青礼物。小小的个人礼物。是的。我确实举办过洋基换物圣诞派对，而且连续好几年每年都办。我其实想把它重新办起来。我停办了几年，因为你知道，生活、孩子还有诸如此类的事情。是的。但我每年都举办洋基换物派对。哦，是的，你办过，而且
was a big party and everyone would come and it got so rowdy. Yeah. My favorite person to have at a Yankee swap party. Yes. Is Oscar Nunez. I was going to say Oscar. Oscar. He makes up chance. Like, like, I remember one of the gifts was like a really lusciously thick fake ponytail. Uh-huh. That you ended up being. I took that home. Yeah. And Oscar like started chance like pony tail. Pony. I mean, they're not really creative chance, but you'd be surprised how much they catch on. I remember one year Lee brought a small hand axe. That thing was super popular. The hot trade. Yes. I want to put it out there guys. If you're going
那是个盛大的派对，每个人都会来，而且气氛超级热烈。是的。在洋基换物派对上我最喜欢的人。是的。是奥斯卡·努涅斯。我正要说奥斯卡。奥斯卡。他会带头喊口号。就像，我记得其中一件礼物是一个非常丰满浓密的假马尾。嗯哼。最后被你拿到了。我把它带回家了。是的。奥斯卡就开始带头喊马尾。马尾。我是说，这些口号其实没什么创意，但你会惊讶于它们有多流行。我记得有一年李带了一把小型手斧。那东西超级受欢迎。抢手货。是的。我想向大家推荐，如果你要去
to a Yankee swap, consider bringing a small axe. Didn't the next year Lee brought a brand new water hose? A garden hose. A garden hose. That was also a hot item. Really popular. Just like practical household items that maybe you need, but you haven't been buying yourself. Well, the next Yankee swap party I have, I'm actually going to include the kids because those were adult only. Oh yeah. And I want to do a family Yankee swap. Okay. Like and invite. The kids are such at the age where they're really getting into it. We went to one last year. But I want you to know, Jennifer, all the people that used to come. So at the end of the night,
参加洋基换物派对，考虑带一把小斧头。第二年李是不是带了一根崭新的水管？花园水管。花园水管。那也是个抢手货。超级受欢迎。就是那种可能需要、但自己一直没买的实用家居用品。嗯，我办的下一个洋基换物派对，我其实要把孩子们也算进去，因为之前的都是成人专属。哦，是的。我想办一个家庭洋基换物派对。好的。就像邀请他们一样。孩子们现在正处于真正开始热衷于此的年纪。我们去年去过一个。但我想让你知道，珍妮弗，所有以前来过的人。所以在派对结束时，
there would be these crap gifts that people would not want. And a friend of mine would unbeknownst to me hide them around my house. I remember this. And I would find them months later. Like cause he really hid them. Yeah. Like up, like sort of on a top shelf by like the spare batteries would be like a weird porcelain clown. Yeah. You know, and Zach Woods brought this gift and he said, Angela, I am the failure of Yankee swap because he brought a Egyptian. The King, the King Tut thing. It was a King Tut miniature sarcophagus. Yeah. That opened up and you could put things inside it. I fought for that. I thought it was really great. I
会有一些大家不想要的垃圾礼物。我的一位朋友在神不知鬼不觉的情况下把它们藏在我家里。我记得这个。几个月后我还会找到它们。因为他藏得真的很深。是的。比如，在备用电池旁边的最高层架子上会有一个奇怪的瓷小丑。是的。你知道的，扎克·伍兹带了这件礼物，他说，安吉拉，我是洋基换物派对的失败者，因为他带了一个埃及风格的。法老，图坦卡蒙的东西。那是一个图坦卡蒙迷你石棺。是的。打开里面还可以放东西。我为那个争取过。我觉得真的很棒。我
loved that. Well, it got traded a bunch and he was like, I don't think anyone likes it. I was like, Zach, you're wrong. I know I'm talking a lot about my Yankee swap party guys, but I was really inspired. Well, this is a side note about Zach Woods. You guys, he played Gabe in later seasons and he became a good friend of ours. When my son was born, he did the same thing. He gave me a gift and he said, I'm so sorry. I'm not good at buying gifts for children. I don't have kids yet. I don't know. And it was this amazing astronaut costume that we still have today and used for dress up. I think he's better at buying gifts than he
很喜欢那个。嗯，它被换了好几次，他说，我觉得没人喜欢它。我说，扎克，你错了。我知道我一直在喋喋不休地讲我的洋基换物派对，伙计们，但我真的是有感而发。好吧，这是一个关于扎克·伍兹的题外话。你们知道吗，他在后面的几季里扮演盖比，成了我们的好朋友。我儿子出生时，他也做了同样的事。他送了我一份礼物，并说，真的很抱歉。我不擅长给小孩子买礼物。我还没有孩子。我不知道。这是一个非常棒的宇航员服装，我们到现在还留着，用来角色扮演。我觉得他其实挺擅长买礼物的，
is. I think you are, Zach. Just FYI. All right. Fast fact number two. This episode was directed by Charles McDougal. Oh, guys, do we have stories about Charles McDougal? I mean, first of all, he was British. Yes. He's British. I'm bringing out the accent. Guys, I did my spin bike and now I'm speaking like a Brit. He had directed before us the HBO series, Rome, which if anyone saw it, is about the Roman Empire and the killing of Julius Caesar. It is epic. It's also brutal. It's brutal. They shot in Malta. There was chariots and horses and people getting impaled. Yes. And so he went from that to our quiet little
我觉得你是，扎克。仅供参考。好的，幕后花絮二。这一集由查尔斯·麦克道格尔执导。哦，伙计们，我们有关于查尔斯·麦克道格尔的故事吗？首先，他是英国人。是的。他是英国人。我要飙一下英国口音了。伙计们，我刚骑完动感单车，现在我说话像个英国人了。在此之前，他曾执导过HBO剧集《罗马》，如果有人看过的话，讲的是罗马帝国和尤利乌斯·恺查的遇刺。非常史诗级。也很残酷。很残酷。他们在马耳他拍摄。有战车、马匹和被穿刺的人。是的。所以他从那种大场面来到了我们安静的
Dunder Mifflin office, a little Christmas party, a little Christmas party. And you guys, the directors that had directed us prior to him were Ken Kuapas, who might be the quietest human on the planet. Correct. He says, you know, when he wants to start a scene, he just says, go ahead. And when he gives a note, he'll say, Jenna, you know what? No, just go ahead. Yeah, that's Ken Kuapas. Yeah. You all heard Paul Feig. Paul Feig is like, hey gang, how's it going? Hey, we're gonna have fun today. Okay, action. Yeah. Charles McDougal rolls in. We're all sitting at our desks quietly about to start the first scene. And he goes, wait, brace
邓德米夫林小办公室，一个小小的圣诞派对，一个小小的圣诞派对。而且你们知道，在他之前执导我们的导演是肯·夸皮斯，他可能是地球上最安静的人了。没错。他说，你知道的，当他想开始一个场景时，他只会说，开始吧。当他给出意见时，他会说，珍娜，你知道吗？不，直接开始吧。是的，那是肯·夸皮斯。是的。你们都听过保罗·费格。保罗·费格就像是，嘿，伙计们，最近怎么样？嘿，我们今天要玩得开心点。好的，开拍。是的。查尔斯·麦克道格尔登场了。我们都安静地坐在办公桌前，准备开始第一场戏。然后他说，等等，抓紧
yourself, brace yourself, brace yourself. Actors, action. Yes. We, I thought Phyllis peed herself a little. I tinkled. I was terrified. I jumped straight up. He was like, oh my gosh. What's happening? What's happening? Is Tom Cruise busting through the ceiling any minute? I'm telling you that first day, the first moment of every scene, we all looked like deer in headlights. We would flinch. We would flinch and then we would go into scene. But then you guys, we just grew to love this guy. Oh, he would say things like we'd be working on a scene and he'd be like, all right, you know, let's go again. Actors, nearly there. Yes. Nearly
扶稳，抓紧扶稳，抓紧扶稳。演员们，开拍。是的。我们，我以为菲利斯吓得有点尿裤子了。我吓漏了一点。我吓坏了。我直接跳了起来。他就像是，哦，天哪。怎么了？怎么了？难道汤姆·克鲁斯随时会破顶而入吗？我告诉你们，第一天，每一场戏的第一个瞬间，我们看起来都像是在车灯前的鹿。我们会退缩。我们会先退缩，然后才进入场景。但随后，伙计们，我们渐渐开始爱上这家伙了。哦，他会说这样的话，我们在排练一场戏，他会说，好吧，你知道的，我们再来一次。演员们，差不多了。是的。差不多
there. Um, and then I one time, he one time said, he said, all right, everyone, that was good for cameras. Actors, better this time. Yeah. Oh, okay. And then as we try to be better this time, as we got into the episode more and the party started, he would walk up to me and be like, Angela, remember, you're really pissed. You're really pissed now. And he sort of, and I'm going to get into it. It's on a, it's on like four or five note cards, but he sort of highlighted the level of, I called it Angela's pissed offness. Yeah. And it had like, it was like building to a crescendo. And so towards the end, he would just yell
了。嗯，然后我有一次，他有一次说，他说，好吧，大家，机器拍得不错。演员们，这次要更好。哦，好吧。然后当我们努力这次表现得更好时，随着我们更多地进入剧情并且派对开始了，他会走到我面前说，安吉拉，记住，你真的很生气。你现在真的很生气。他有点，而且我会详细讲。这写在大约四五张便签卡上，但他某种程度上强调了那种程度的，我称之为安吉拉的愤怒值。是的。而且它就像是在层层递进。所以在快结束时，他会直接大喊，
before a big take in the party. He'd be like, all right, everyone happy. Angela pissed and action. Yes. It was amazing. It was amazing. I just think it's so interesting that he went from filming all these chariots to filming people in a circle. Yeah. Sitting in a circle. What was that like for him on desk chairs? Yes. Okay. Fast fact number three, Bob Vance, Vance refrigeration. We meet Phyllis's boyfriend. Yes, her new boyfriend. He works across the hall. He's played by Bobby Ray Schaefer. He went on to do 24 episodes of the office, including our finale. So here's a little tidbit. Mike Scherr, our writer, said that the way
在派对的一个大镜头之前。他会说，好吧，大家开心。安吉拉生气，开拍。是的。太棒了。太棒了。我只是觉得很有趣，他从拍摄所有这些战车转变为拍摄围成一圈的人。是的。围成一圈坐着。对坐在办公椅上的他来说，那是什么体验？好的，幕后花絮三，鲍勃·范斯，范斯制冷公司。我们遇到了菲利斯的男友。是的，她的新男友。他在大厅对面工作。由鲍比·雷·谢弗饰演。他后来出演了24集《办公室》，包括我们的结局。这里有个小花絮。迈克·肖尔，我们的编剧，说鲍勃·范斯总是自我介绍的方式
that Bob Vance always introduces himself as Bob Vance, Vance refrigeration, is based on a friend of his, actor Hayes MacArthur, who he says, for years would introduce himself as Hayes MacArthur, Chicago, Illinois. Hayes MacArthur, Chicago, Illinois. You guys, you might know Hayes. He would later go on to start with Rashida Jones and Angie Tribeca, which was created by Steve and Nancy Carell. Small world. Small world. But I feel comfortable sharing that story about Hayes because I know him as well. And Mike said it on the DVD commentary. So he shared that with us on set. But since he put it out there, I
是鲍勃·范斯，范斯制冷公司，是基于他的一个朋友，演员海斯·麦克阿瑟，他说这个人多年来一直自我介绍说是海斯·麦克阿瑟，伊利诺伊州芝加哥。海斯·麦克阿瑟，伊利诺伊州芝加哥。你们可能会认识海斯。他后来与拉什达·琼斯一起主演了《安吉丽娜·特里贝卡》，该剧由史蒂夫和南希·卡瑞尔创作。世界真小。世界真小。但我很乐意分享关于海斯的故事，因为我也认识他。而且迈克在DVD评论中说过。所以他在片场跟我们分享过。既然他公开了，我
was like, well, Mike, you already said it. So I'm gonna share it here. Yeah. Well, you know what? I think that some people do that. I mean, I know in my hometown, you know, I'm from a very small town in Texas. And there are people in my town that we, no one ever says just their first name. I don't know why, but my mom's really good friend. Her first name is Sue and her last name is Dean. But every one of the town calls her Sue Dean. Oh, yeah. Hi, Sue Dean. How are you, Sue Dean? It'd be like, Jenna Fisher. How are you, Jenna Fisher? I'm good, Jenna Fisher. I mean, it's so, there are some people whose names just, you just
就想，好吧，迈克，你已经说过了。所以我在这里分享一下。好吧，你知道吗？我觉得有些人确实会这样。我的意思是，我知道在我的家乡，你知道，我来自德克萨斯州的一个小镇。镇上有些人，我们，从来没有人只叫他们的名字。我不知道为什么，但我妈妈的一个好朋友。她的名字叫苏，姓迪恩。但镇上的每个人都叫她苏·迪恩。哦，是的。嗨，苏·迪恩。你好吗，苏·迪恩？这就好像是，珍娜·费舍尔。你好吗，珍娜·费舍尔？我很好，珍娜·费舍尔。我的意思是，这太，有些人名字就是这样，你自然而然就会
do that. Yeah. Well, we had some fans right in and ask, why does he always say Bob Vance? Vance refrigeration. It was inspired by one of Mike's friends. I love it. Many people, before we go to break, many people wrote in to tell us that Mindy's hair is down. I've, I've maybe not received so many. In this episode? No, it's in this episode. No, it's down. No, it's partially up. It's partially up. Oh, well, Jennifer Danette said that Mindy's hair is down. Jennifer Danette, I'm going to send you a screen grab. I mean, maybe she means down because it's not in the French twist. It's not in the French twist, but she has
那样做。是的。好吧，有一些粉丝写信来问，为什么他总是说鲍勃·范斯？范斯制冷。这是受到迈克的一个朋友的启发。我喜欢。很多人，在我们休息之前，很多人写信告诉我们敏迪的头发是放下来的。我可能，我可能没收到那么多。在这一集中？不，是在这一集中。不，它是放下来的。不，它是半扎起来的。它是半扎起来的。哦，好吧，珍妮弗·德内特说敏迪的头发是放下来的。珍妮弗·德内特，我要给你发个截图。我的意思是，也许她说的放下来是因为它没有盘成法式发髻。它没有盘成法式发髻，但她
had a few. It is. It's half up, half down. She's had a few half up, half downs, but I would say there's more down than up. Jennifer, there's more down than up. That's what she said? Well, I hope she doesn't say that. Wow. We would hope there's more up than down. Alright, let's go to break. Alright, so let's dive in here. We've got the cold open in the very first few seconds. Pam is stuffing the Christmas envelopes, the Christmas photo. Yeah, right? She's doing the Christmas card mass mailing. The Christmas card. I did this at 1-800-DENNEST. Oh, you did the 1-800-DENNEST company Christmas card mailing? I did. I volunteered and you got to hop off the
有过几次。确实是。它是半扎半放的。她有过几次半扎半放，但我会说放下来的比扎起来的多。珍妮弗，放下来的比扎起来的多。她是这么说的吗？嗯，我希望她没这么说。哇。我们希望扎起来的比放下来的多。好吧，我们去休息一下。好的，让我们深入探讨一下。我们在最初的几秒钟里看到了冷场开场。潘正在装圣诞信封，圣诞照片。是的，对吧？她在批量邮寄圣诞卡。圣诞卡。我在1-800-DENNEST做过这个。哦，你做过1-800-DENNEST公司的圣诞卡批量邮寄？我做过。我自愿去的，这样你就可以不用
phone so you didn't have to talk to people about, like, their rotten teeth. Yeah. And I would go in the mailroom and they'd be playing Christmas music and I'd have a cup of tea and I would just stuff envelopes all day and I was so happy. Oh, yeah. I did many, many mass mailings as an administrative assistant. I'd have to bind things, copy on both sides, collate, bind and mail. I am very happy doing those things. Okay, but the photo was our cast photo that we took, our Christmas photo. It was not our Christmas photo. What? Oh, yeah. It was, I, listen, I maybe got a little too obsessed with it, but I thought I recognized it. I screwed up it. It was, me too. It's our season one publicity photo from the pilot.
接电话，就不用跟别人谈论诸如他们烂牙之类的事情了。是的。我会去收发室，他们会放着圣诞音乐，我有一杯茶，我整天都在装信封，我感到非常快乐。哦，是的。作为一名行政助理，我做过很多次批量邮寄。我得装订文件、双面复印、配页、装订和邮寄。做这些事情我非常开心。好的，但那张照片是我们拍的演员照，我们的圣诞照片。那不是我们的圣诞照片。什么？哦，是的。那是，我，听着，我可能有点太痴迷了，但我以为我认出来了。我搞砸了。那是，我也是。那是我们第一季试播集的宣传照。
You're right, because I'm sitting in the front. Oh my gosh. And we're not wearing any Christmas stuff. Oh, Jenna, good catch. I, I totally just thought it was our Christmas picture. Well, we had a fan question from Pizuki. Did anyone keep a copy of the holiday card Pam is stuffing into the envelopes at the beginning? Well, I don't have a copy of the card, but I have a copy of that picture hanging in my office. And I examined it against the card that Pam is putting into the envelopes. Well, remember in the pilot. Who's my detective? Henriette. Thank you so much. CSI office ladies. Henriette is in that photo. Henriette is in the photo on my wall because she was in the pilot. They photoshopped Kate's head onto Henriette's body
你说的对，因为我坐在最前面。哦，天哪。而且我们没穿任何圣诞服装。哦，珍娜，好眼力。我，我完全以为那是我们的圣诞照片。好吧，我们有一个来自皮祖基的粉丝提问。有没有人留着潘在开头塞进信封里的那张节日卡的副本？嗯，我没有那张卡的副本，但我有一张那张照片的副本挂在我的办公室里。我把它和潘塞进信封里的卡片进行了对比。好吧，还记得试播集吗。我的侦探是谁？亨利埃特。非常感谢。CSI办公室女士。亨利埃特就在那张照片里。亨利埃特在我墙上的照片里，因为她出演了试播集。他们把凯特的头P到了亨利埃特的身体上
for the picture I'm stuffing into the envelope. I really want that card. Dang it. Yeah, because I can see it's Henriette's hand on her hip in the sweater that's hanging in my office, but Kate's face. Way to go, Jenna. So far, we've covered one second of the episode that happens in the first one to three seconds. The next thing that happens is that Michael and Dwight enter with the tree and it's really way too big. It's way too big. It goes through the ceiling. I feel like this is a little nod to Christmas vacation. Yes. You know, with Chevy Chase and that enormous tree. Yes. Well, do you remember when we were on set about three or four times when they pushed it up, the ceiling towel actually fell down and would fall on Steve's head. And then they'd have to brush him off with
做成了我塞进信封的那张照片。我真的很想要那张卡片。可恶。是的，因为我能看到挂在我办公室毛衣上放在臀部的亨利埃特的手，但却是凯特的脸。干得好，珍娜。到目前为止，我们只讲了这一集发生在前一到三秒钟的一秒钟内容。接下来发生的是迈克尔和德怀特抬着圣诞树进来，真的太大了。太大了。直接顶到了天花板。我觉得这有点是在向《疯狂假期》致敬。是的。你知道的，雪佛·切斯和那棵巨大的树。嗯，你还记得我们在片场时，当他们三四次把树推上去时，天花板瓷砖实际上掉了下来，砸到了史蒂夫的头上。然后他们不得不帮他刷掉
a little brush and fix his hair. There was little pieces of white sort of like particle looking stuff all over the ground. Yeah. Because the ceiling kept busting apart. Yeah. I loved that Kevin cuts the top of the Christmas tree with a paper trimmer. Yeah. I just thought that was such a nice touch. Well, it makes sense. It's what we'd have. It's what we would have. Yeah. Okay. I did kind of an Angela thing. What's that? Did you drink Rose during the day? I did not, but I did. I wrote down everybody's Christmas outfits. I love this. So did I. You did? Okay. Let's do it. Let's do it. Okay. All right. I noticed that Michael has a Christmas tie. Yes, he does. It has a Santa on it and some snowman. Go. Christmas tie, Kevin. Yes. Snowman,
一个小刷子，帮他整理头发。地上到处都是像颗粒状的小块白色东西。是的。因为天花板一直在散架。是的。我喜欢凯文用切纸机切掉圣诞树顶。是的。我只是觉得这是一个非常好的细节。好吧，这很合理。这就是我们会做的。这就是我们会做的。是的。好吧，我做了一件很安吉拉的事。什么事？你在白天喝了桃红葡萄酒吗？我没有，但我做了。我记下了每个人的圣诞服装。我喜欢这个。我也是。你做了吗？好吧。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。好的。好的。我注意到迈克尔系着一条圣诞领带。是的，他确实系了。上面有一个圣诞老人和几个雪人。继续。圣诞领带，凯文。是的。雪人，
wintry scene. All right. You and I both only have a Christmas pin and Christmas earrings. You have Christmas ornament earrings. I have Christmas stocking earrings and we both have a version of a Santa Claus pin. Interesting. We're dressed kind of similar. Very similarly. What's that about? I don't know, but Phyllis has a full Christmas blouse and vest. I love her Christmas vest. My sister's a school teacher and she does that. Like at Christmas time, she wears all these Christmas sweaters and vests. You know I love this stuff. I've got all of it. My mom back in St. Louis, Missouri, every year she goes to the local art fairs and craft fairs, and she sends me Christmas hoodies, Christmas vests, Christmas pajamas, Christmas everything.
冬景。好的。你和我都只有一枚圣诞胸针和圣诞耳环。你戴着圣诞装饰品耳环。我戴着圣诞袜耳环，而且我们俩都戴着某种版本的圣诞老人胸针。有趣。我们穿得有点像。非常相似。那是怎么回事？我不知道，但菲利斯穿着全套圣诞衬衫和马甲。我喜欢她的圣诞马甲。我姐姐是个学校老师，她就那样穿。比如在圣诞节期间，她会穿所有这些圣诞毛衣和马甲。你知道我喜欢这些。我全都有。我在密苏里州圣路易斯的妈妈，每年都会去当地的艺术展和工艺品展，她会寄给我圣诞连帽衫、圣诞马甲、圣诞睡衣、圣诞一切。
I mean, those earrings could have been yours because you've come to my house at Christmas and you always have on Christmas jewelry. I'll tell you right now, I would never show up at a Christmas party and only Christmas earrings and Christmas pin. I know. I mean, that is. I know. I go all out. You go all out. Oh, Oscar has a Christmas tie. Oscar has a Christmas tie. Stanley has a red tie. So I guess that's his attempt. Very Stanley. That's as far as he would go. I'm actually surprised he went that far for Stanley. I know. Also, Meredith has a crazy Christmas sweater. Yeah. See, if it were me, I would be Meredith or Phyllis showing up to your party. Full outfit. I know. I've seen how you come to my party. I love it. All right. So in this scene
我的意思是，那些耳环本可以是你的，因为你圣诞节来我家时，总是戴着圣诞首饰。我现在就告诉你，我绝不会只戴着圣诞耳环和圣诞胸针就出现在圣诞派对上。我知道。我的意思是，那是。我知道。我会全力以赴。你会全力以赴。哦，奥斯卡系了一条圣诞领带。奥斯卡系了一条圣诞领带。斯坦利系了一条红领带。所以我猜那是他的尝试。很符合斯坦利的风格。这就是他所能做到的极限了。我其实很惊讶斯坦利能做到这一点。我知道。还有，梅雷迪思穿着一件疯狂的圣诞毛衣。是的。看，如果是我，我就会像梅雷迪思或菲利斯那样出现在你的派对上。全套盛装。我知道。我见过你是怎么去我的派对的。我很喜欢。好的。所以在这一场戏中
that's coming up, Jim reveals that he got Pam in Secret Santa. He does. Can I listen, Jim fans, you're probably not going to like me for saying this, but at two minutes, two seconds, in his talking head, he says he wants, you know, he got Pam for Secret Santa and he said because Pam wants a teapot so she can make tea at her desk. Yeah. And I wrote WTF. Who makes tea at their desk? She would go in the kitchen. What is she going to do? Go to the kitchen, put the hot water in the teapot, carry it back to her desk, pour herself a cup of tea at her desk. She's going to carry that teapot from the kitchen. What part of this is confusing you? I think is ridiculous. Okay. Here's her other option. Okay. Yeah. She goes into the kitchen.
这个马上就要播了，吉姆透露他在神秘圣诞老人抽签里抽到了帕姆。确实是。等等，听我说，吉姆的粉丝们，你们可能不会喜欢我这么说，但在两分零二秒的时候，在他的单人访谈里，他说他想，你知道的，他为神秘圣诞老人抽到了帕姆，他说因为帕姆想要一个茶壶，这样她就能在办公桌上泡茶了。对。而我写的是“操，什么鬼”。谁在办公桌上泡茶？她应该去茶水间。她打算怎么做？去茶水间，把热水倒进茶壶里，把它拿回她的桌子，在她的桌子上给自己倒一杯茶。她要把那个茶壶从茶水间端过来。这有什么让你觉得困惑的？我觉得这太荒谬了。好吧。这是她的另一个选择。好吧。对。她走进茶水间。
Yeah. Oh, I see the breakdown. I see how your brain is tracking it and why it doesn't make sense. And also because I know you and you just put the teabag right into the cup, which is a totally acceptable way to make it. I know some people let it, let it seep. Steep. Steep. Steep. With a tea. Let it seep on in there. You leave it in your pot. That's right. I said that the scene could be called something else. What could it be called? Instead of what's inside the teapot, it could be called Jim's Got It Bad. Oh. Because he saved two sauce packets from a few years ago. Yeah. That's someone who has got it really bad. Okay. I, I, yeah. Yeah. I feel like that could
对。哦，我懂了，我明白你的思路了，也明白为什么这说不通了。而且因为我了解你，你总是直接把茶包放进杯子里，这绝对是一种可以接受的泡茶方式。我知道有些人会让它，让它浸泡。浸泡。浸泡。用茶。让它泡在里面。你把它留在壶里。没错。我说过，那个场景可以叫别的名字。叫什么好呢？与其叫茶壶里有什么，不如叫吉姆陷得很深。哦。因为他留着几年前用过的两包酱料。对。那是陷得真的很深的人。好吧。我，我，对。对。我觉得那段可以
have been written a little differently where Jim could have said a couple of years ago, Pam did this thing with the hot sauce and therefore I am putting a packet of hot sauce in there. The fact that he saved the two packets of hot sauce. For years. For years. Yeah. He loves you. He loves you. Okay. Definitely does. All right. Well, I do have a lot to say about the teapot. So first of all, Phil Shea offered me a variety of teapots before we started shooting in many colors and I picked the teal. I love it. Yeah. I don't know. Little pop of color. The writers also said that picking what this gift would be, the fact that it would be a teapot provided a major challenge because they needed a gift that could hide other gifts
写得稍微有点不同，吉姆本可以说几年前，帕姆用辣酱做过这种事，因此我在里面放了一包辣酱。事实上他竟然留着那两包辣酱。留了好几年。留了好几年。对。他爱你。他爱你。好吧。绝对是。好吧，关于这个茶壶，我确实有很多话要说。首先，在我们开拍之前，菲尔·谢伊为我提供了各种颜色的茶壶，我挑了蓝绿色。我很喜欢。对。我不知道。带有一点亮色。编剧们还说，挑选这个礼物会是什么，也就是它会是一个茶壶，这带来了巨大的挑战，因为他们需要一个能够藏起其他礼物的礼物
that was really personal and that would be very stressful when Dwight takes it away from Pam. It could only cost $20 and it had to be something that Dwight really wanted. And they said it was not easy. They spent a very long time because they knew plot-wise what had to happen that Jim gives Pam a gift filled with secret treasures that Dwight also wants to have that costs under $20. It took them a very long time to come up with teapot. For that reason alone, okay, fine. Pam can make her tea at the counter. She can speak on theater desk. Because when Dwight puts it in his nose, I know that's later, but it's so perfect. It is. It's so perfect. I mean, they nailed it, right? They nailed it. And now this teapot is famous.
而且它必须非常个人化，当德怀特从帕姆那里把它拿走时，这会非常有压力。它只能花20美元，而且必须是德怀特真正想要的东西。他们说这可不容易。他们花了很长时间，因为他们从剧情上知道接下来会发生什么——吉姆送给帕姆一个装满了秘密宝藏的礼物，而德怀特也想要得到它，并且价格在20美元以下。他们花了很长很长时间才想出茶壶这个点子。仅凭这一点，好吧，行。帕姆可以在柜台上泡茶。她可以在她的办公桌上说话。因为当德怀特把它塞进鼻子时，我知道那是后来的事，但它太完美了。确实是。太完美了。我是说，他们成功了，对吧？他们成功了。现在这个茶壶出名了。
I mean, all the time people are using this teapot idea to propose to their loved ones. I see it all the time and my Instagram people are tagging me. It's always charming to me. It's always so sweet. It is very thoughtful. So we mentioned the things that he's putting into the teapot. Here's a fan question. Taylor Rilling said, what is the significance of the pencil that Jim puts in the teapot? Yeah, he said that the story is too long. So we have a deleted scene and I remember shooting it. What Pam says when she picks up the pencil is she says, oh my gosh, this is the pencil I threw at you during mini golf. What? When did Jim and Pam go play mini golf? Maybe the whole office went and played mini golf. That seems like something Michael Scott would be like,
我是说，人们总是在用这个茶壶的主意向他们爱的人求婚。我经常看到，我的Instagram上经常有人@我。这对我来说总是很迷人。总是那么甜蜜。确实非常贴心。所以我们提到了他塞进茶壶里的东西。这是一个粉丝提问。泰勒·里林说，吉姆放进茶壶里的那支铅笔有什么意义？对，他说那个故事太长了。所以我们有一个删减片段，我记得我们拍过。帕姆拿起铅笔时说的是，天哪，这就是我在迷你高尔夫球场上朝你扔的那支铅笔。什么？吉姆和帕姆什么时候去打过迷你高尔夫？也许整个办公室都去打迷你高尔夫了。这听起来像是迈克尔·斯科特会做的事，
we're going to play mini golf and we're going to raise money for my neighbors like whatever. That's all I can think of is that there was some office outing where they went and played mini golf and I guess Pam got all feisty and threw a pencil at him and he saved it. So that's where the pencil is. And then of course he puts a card in the box and he says, because Christmas time is the time to tell people how you feel. Oh yeah, that's so loaded. I have PPC next. Let's hit some PPC, the party planning committee. Mike Scherr also wrote the PPC and the alliance. I think he likes the PPC. He definitely likes the PPC and their weird sort of power struggle. He loves it. Well, in this scene, we find out that Ryan has been drafted into the PPC. I can't believe that.
我们要去打迷你高尔夫，我们要为我的邻居们筹款之类的。我能想到的就是有一次办公室集体出游，他们去打迷你高尔夫，我猜帕姆当时好胜心强，朝他扔了一支铅笔，而他把它留作纪念了。所以铅笔就是这么来的。然后当然他在盒子里放了一张卡片，他说，因为圣诞节是向人们倾诉心声的时刻。哦，对，话里有话。接下来是PPC。我们来聊聊PPC，也就是派对策划委员会。迈克·舒尔也写了PPC和同盟。我觉得他喜欢PPC。他绝对喜欢PPC以及他们那种奇怪的权力斗争。他很喜欢。好吧，在这个场景中，我们发现瑞恩被征召进PPC了。我简直不敢相信。
I remember that. I can't believe that Angela Martin would recruit him, except that maybe she needed help like someone setting up things and moving things. Well, the Christmas party is a big one. It's a big one. Yeah. Yeah. But also I noticed that Meredith is in there. Yeah. No, it's all hands on deck. She probably has a bigger crew than just her core crew. Well, that's when Michael enters in his Santa beard. He throws down some cash because he wants a bigger, better party and he reveals he has a digital camera and he will be taking photos. Yeah. And he's going to put him in the newsletter. Most embarrassing one wins. Yes. I want you guys to know when Steve came behind Phyllis and I and he was like, I want people making out. And he shoved her heads together and was
我记得那个。我简直不敢相信安吉拉·马丁会招募他，除非她可能需要人帮忙，比如布置场地和搬东西。好吧，圣诞派对是个大活动。是个大活动。对。对。不过我也注意到梅雷迪思也在里面。对。不，全员出动了。她手下可能不仅有核心团队，还有更多人。好吧，这就是迈克尔戴着圣诞老人胡子登场的时候。他扔下一些现金，因为他想要一个更大更好的派对，并且他透露他有一台数码相机，他会拍照。对。而且他会把照片放进通讯里。最尴尬的一张获胜。是的。我想让你们知道，当史蒂夫走到菲莉丝和我身后时，他说我想要看到人们热吻。然后他把我们的头推到一起，说
like, that was an impromptu. That was impromptu. Yeah. Phyllis and I didn't know that was coming. He just did it in the moment. I was really proud that neither of us started laughing. I was so proud of myself because there were a few times in that scene I almost broke and I was really fighting it. Oh, it's also in the scene Angela that it's revealed that Phyllis was in charge of getting the lights for the Christmas tree. And she said she got the little ones. Yeah. And you have a reaction to that. Well, that's not going to go over well later. That is not going to go over. So I did, like I said, I listened to the DVD commentary of this and Mike was really good on the commentary at breaking down some of his goals for the episode. And his goal for the episode
那是即兴发挥。那是即兴的。对。菲莉丝和我事先都不知道。他当时就那么做了。我真的很骄傲，我们两个都没有笑出来。我为自己感到骄傲，因为那个场景里有好几次我差点笑场，我一直在极力克制。哦，也是在这个场景里，安吉拉，大家发现菲莉丝负责买圣诞树的彩灯。她说她买的是小号的。对。你对此有反应。好吧，这事后来可不好收场。这绝对不好收场。所以我确实像我说的，我听了这集的DVD评论音轨，迈克在评论里真的很擅长剖析他为这一集设定的一些目标。他这一集的目标
was that Angela would get more and more and more stressed out every scene that we see her. And I think you can track that. Like as I was watching it again, I can totally see that. I have five note cards called Angela's Pissed Offness. Yes. That I'm going to start with timecode soon. Before we get into all that, I do have to point out because I was texting with Kim Ferry who did my hair for nine years on the office last night. This is the Angela hair braid. That is my actual hair that she had me bend over and braid. And of course my character would want to wear it to the Christmas party. I feel like this was her special braid. For special occasions. For special occasions. And while we're talking PPC guys, I have to say Pam, Pam would probably
就是让安吉拉在每一个出场的场景中变得越来越焦虑。我觉得你能看出来。当我再次观看时，我完全能看出来。我有五张写着“安吉拉气炸了”的索引卡。是的。我很快就会开始记录时间码。在我们深入探讨这一切之前，我必须指出来，因为昨晚我和金·费里发过短信，她在《办公室》剧组负责给我做九年头发。这就是安吉拉的辫子头。那是我的真发，她让我弯下腰编的。当然，我的角色会想在圣诞派对上戴着它。我觉得这是她的专属辫子。为了特殊场合。为了特殊场合。而且在聊PPC的时候，伙计们，我必须说帕姆，帕姆可能
irk me too on this committee. What? I mean, at four minutes, 25 seconds, Angela is trying to put a tablecloth on this table. Pam is just staring at her doing nothing, not trying to grab for the tablecloth, help her spread it out, anything. And Angela just looks at her and is just like, will you help me? When I saw that scene, I found it so satisfying. It's her little bit of defiance against your just crazy controlling. Yes. Yes. Just your everything that's coming at her. And you know, I told you I go back and I read my journals and I had written and I also have these old blogs. And I had written in one of my old blogs that filming the scene where I don't help you put the tablecloth on was one of my favorites of the whole episode. It's such like passive aggressive
在这个委员会里也会惹恼我。什么？我是说，在四分二十五秒时，安吉拉正试图在这张桌子上铺桌布。帕姆就只是盯着她什么也不做，不打算去拿桌布，帮她铺开，什么都不做。而安吉拉只是看着她，然后说，你能帮我一下吗？当我看到那个场景时，我感到太满足了。这是她对你那种疯狂控制欲的一点点反抗。是的。是的。就是针对她的一切。你知道的，我告诉过你，我回去读了我的日记，我写过，我还有这些旧博客。我在其中一篇旧博客里写过，拍摄我不帮你铺桌布那个场景是我整集中最喜欢的一场戏。这真是一种被动攻击式的
defiance. I loved it. I loved it. Well, Jenna, I went and found my MySpace blogs. So they're not online anymore. I don't know why, but I guess I had printed them out at some point. Smart. So now I'm going to start going to them for each episode. And I did for this one, but I'll save it for a bit because it happens later in the episode. Okay, great. Fan question from small actor in a pea coat. Who kept the camera with all of the pictures that Michael took? NBC. Yeah. They were property of NBC and they had them up on their website for a while. But guess what? You can still find them. And Jenna and I were texting last night. We both found them over at officetally.com. Yeah. So you can see all those pictures that he was really taking pictures. Yeah. And they're
反抗。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。好吧，珍娜，我去找了我的MySpace博客。它们现在已经不在网上播出了。我不知道为什么，但我猜我当时在某个时候把它们打印出来了。真聪明。所以现在我要开始为每一集翻看它们了。这一集我也看了，但我先留着不讲，因为这发生在这一集的后面部分。好的，棒极了。来自穿呢子大衣的小演员的粉丝提问。谁保管着迈克尔拍的所有照片的相机？NBC。对。它们是NBC的财产，并在他们的网站上展示了一段时间。但你猜怎么着？你仍然可以找到它们。昨晚我和珍娜还发短信来着。我们在officetally.com上都找到了。对。所以你可以看到那些他真的在拍的照片。对。而且它们
really like not centered and like people's heads are cut off. It's as if he just went around clicking away, but there's some real gyms in there. I know. Six minutes, 54 seconds. Michael really, really shows what he thinks about Christmas, which is a gift should say, I love you this mini dollars worth. Yeah. Oh, this is not going to go well. Well, speaking of gifts, we have a scene where Toby reveals what he got Angela in Secret Santa and it is the jazz baby poster. Yeah. I have that poster guys. You have it. That was one of my questions from Chris Cordova. He wants to know, did you keep the baby poster? Well, there was about 20 of them. They made a bunch. One hung by my desk for years. Yes. Yeah. So we got to see it every day. And I have one. It's
真的非常没有对焦，比如人们的头都被切掉了。就好像他只是到处乱按快门，但里面确实有一些真正的宝藏。我知道。六分五十四秒。迈克尔真的，真的展现了他对圣诞节的看法，那就是一份礼物应该表达，我爱你价值这么多美元。对。哦，这下要糟了。好吧，说到礼物，我们有一个场景，托比透露了他在神秘圣诞老人抽签里送给安吉拉的礼物，是一张爵士宝贝海报。对。我有那张海报，伙计们。你有。那是克里斯·科尔多瓦的其中一个问题。他想知道，你留下了那张婴儿海报吗？好吧，大概有20张。他们做了很多。一张挂在我的桌子旁好多年。对。对。所以我们每天都能看到它。我有一张。它是
rolled up in a little poster thingy. Now, do you know the story behind that picture? Because I traded some text messages with Phil Shea. So Phil Shea had to make that poster. He did not buy that poster. He put out a casting call for babies. And two babies were cast, baby actors. He said it was really hard to find tiny jazz instruments. He said that was really difficult. In fact, he said, you know, Amazon didn't exist back then. You know, you couldn't just Google baby jazz instrument. And they couldn't be fake looking like they couldn't be like blue and pink. So he did eventually find them at a place called Hollywood Costumes. He was particularly proud of the tiny sunglasses that he found. This poster
卷在一个小海报筒里的。那么，你知道那张照片背后的故事吗？因为我和菲尔·谢伊发了一些短信。所以菲尔·谢伊必须制作那张海报。他不是买的那张海报。他发布了一个婴儿的选角通告。有两个婴儿被选上了，也就是小演员。他说要找到微型的乐器真的很难。他说那真的很难。事实上，他说，你知道的，那时候亚马逊并不存在。你知道的，你不能随便在谷歌上搜索婴儿爵士乐器。而且它们不能看起来很假，比如不能是蓝色和粉红色的。所以他最终在一家叫做“好莱坞服装”的地方找到了它们。他对他找到的微型太阳镜感到特别自豪。这张海报
ends up coming back in conflict resolution. Like you said, it stayed up there, but then it comes back again. It comes back again. I would like to know the two babies that were in the poster. Oh, guys, where are they today? If you are a baby in the baby jazz poster, will you please write to us at officeladies at earwolf.com. One thing about that baby jazz poster, I remember Mike Scher telling me that they thought it was really funny that Angela would really enjoy babies dressed as adults. Okay, where are we? Well, we're talking about the gifts. And Mike Scher actually said that the gifts were incredibly hard to manage because they start off as Secret Santa. So everybody had a person that they bought a specific gift for. And then you had to track the
最后在《冲突解决》里再次出现了。正如你所说，它一直挂在那儿，但后来又出现了。它又出现了。我很想知道海报里的那两个婴儿是谁。哦，伙计们，他们今天在哪里？如果你是婴儿爵士海报里的那个婴儿，请给我们写信至officeladies@earwolf.com。关于那张婴儿爵士海报，我记得迈克·舒尔告诉我，他们觉得安吉拉会非常喜欢打扮成成年人的婴儿，这非常搞笑。好的，我们讲到哪儿了？我们在聊礼物。迈克·舒尔实际上说过，这些礼物极其难以管理，因为它们一开始是神秘圣诞老人。所以每个人都为一个人买了一份特定的礼物。然后你必须追踪
gifts as they went around in the Yankee swap. He actually in the script of this episode, there is a whole page where he lists the gifts. Who bought who what? And he did this for Vada, our script supervisor. We haven't really talked about her, but Vada's job is to sit and watch every take that is filmed and make notes about everything that happens continuity wise. So, I mean, like really specific. So like, if in a scene, you take a drink of your tea on a certain line and then scratch your nose on another one, Vada writes it down so that you do it the same every time for editing purposes. Yeah, Vada would come up to us and say, Angela, you were holding that pen in your left hand in the first take. And in the second take, you picked it up and held it
礼物在白色大象交换派对中的流转。实际上，在这集的剧本里，有一整页他列出的礼物。谁给谁买的什么？他是为我们的剧务瓦达做的这件事。我们还没怎么聊过她，但瓦达的工作是坐着观看拍摄的每一个镜头，并记下关于连续性的所有事情的笔记。我是说，非常具体。所以，如果在某个场景中，你在某句台词时喝了一口茶，然后在另一句台词时挠了挠鼻子，瓦达会把它记下来，这样为了剪辑的目的，你在每个镜头里都要做得一模一样。对，瓦达会走到我们面前说，安吉拉，你在第一个镜头里是用左手拿那支笔的。而在第二个镜头里，你把它拿起来拿在
in your right hand. So that's not going to match. So you need to pick which hand you're going to hold that pen in and do it in every take the same way. Yeah, because otherwise, when you edit it together, the pen is magically bouncing from hand to hand. So Mike was really worried about Vada in this episode. And so he made this list just for Vada. And I have it from the script. Oh, fantastic. Okay, so this is what everyone was intended to give. And we got a lot of fan questions about this. Like a lot of people wrote in and said, you know, eventually Michael's going to get the paintball lessons from Dwight. But they're like, who did Dwight intend that to go to? So I have all the answers right here. Are you ready? Yeah. Okay. Dwight got Phyllis, the paintball lessons
右手。所以这不搭。所以你需要选定你要用哪只手拿那支笔，并且在每个镜头里都用同样的方式做。对，因为否则，当你把它剪辑在一起时，这支笔就会神奇地在两只手之间跳跃。所以迈克这一集里真的很担心瓦达。因此他专门为瓦达制作了这个清单。我从剧本里拿到了它。哦，太棒了！好的，所以这是每个人原本要送的礼物。我们收到了很多关于这个的粉丝提问。就像很多人写信来说，你知道的，迈克尔最终会从德怀特那里得到彩弹射击课。但他们想问的是，德怀特原本打算把这个送给谁？所以我这里有所有的答案。准备好了吗？对。好的。德怀特把彩弹射击课
and the pellets. That was his gift to Phyllis. Phyllis made Michael an oven mitt. Michael got Ryan an iPod. Ryan got Toby a book of short stories by George Saunders, who happens to be one of Mike Sharer's favorite writers. Toby got Angela the baby poster. Angela bought Stanley a picture frame. Stanley got Kelly a name plate. Kelly got Oscar a shower radio. Oscar got Creed a shamrock keychain. Creed got Jim one of his own shirts. Jim got Pam the teapot. And this is something that got cut out. Pam made Meredith a drawing of the office. I read about that online. Yeah. And there was this big thing. It's in the deleted scenes. This is something I have to tell you. I got a DVD player for Christmas. What? My husband got me a DVD player. So I got the CDs. He bought me the CD set,
和彩弹送给了菲莉丝。那是他送给菲莉丝的礼物。菲莉丝给迈克尔做了一个隔热手套。迈克尔给瑞恩买了一个iPod。瑞恩给托比买了一本乔治·桑德斯的短篇小说集，乔治·桑德斯恰好是迈克·舒尔最喜欢的作家之一。托比给安吉拉买了婴儿海报。安吉拉给斯坦利买了一个相框。斯坦利给凯利买了一个名牌。凯利给奥斯卡买了一个浴室收音机。奥斯卡给克里德买了一个三叶草钥匙扣。克里德给吉姆买了他自己的衬衫之一。吉姆给帕姆买了茶壶。这是被剪掉的一部分。帕姆给梅雷迪思画了一张办公室的画。我在网上看到过这个。对。并且有这么一件大事。它在删减片段里。这是我必须告诉你的一件事。我圣诞节收到了一台DVD播放机。什么？我丈夫给我买了一台DVD播放机。所以我得到了光盘，
and I got a DVD player. And last night I got to watch all the deleted scenes. Oh, Angela, you must be so happy. I was so happy. And there's so many. Oh, yeah. There's so many. For the Christmas episode, you guys, there are so many great deleted scenes. I don't want to get us off topic here. But they're in the deleted scenes. Meredith opens up her painting. That is from Pam. And it's a drawing of the office. Well, there's a big backstory here, again, with Phil. I don't do Pam's drawings. People ask me that all the time. I'm not an artist. I mean, we've talked about this or have we that I do cartoons. I do cartooning. She's very good at cartooning. And I have a few that you've drawn that I've saved.
他给我买了一套光盘，我还得到了一台DVD播放机。昨晚我看了所有的删减片段。哦，安吉拉，你一定太高兴了。我太高兴了。有那么多。哦，是的。有那么多。对于圣诞节那一集，你们知道的，有那么多精彩的删减片段。我不想让我们偏离正题。但它们就在删减片段里。梅雷迪思打开了她的画。那是来自帕姆的。那是办公室的一幅画。这里其实有一个很大的幕后故事，还是关于菲尔的。我可不画帕姆的画。人们经常问我这个。我不是艺术家。我是说，我们聊过这个吗？或者说我画的是漫画。我画漫画。她很擅长画漫画。我保存了几个你画的。
I think you're fantastic. Well, I love my little expressive cartoons, but I needed Pam and wanted Pam to be a better artist than I am. So there is a young art student that does all of Pam's drawings. They went out to a bunch of people, like 12 different artists to as to turn in samples to be the artist behind Pam. And they picked a young woman. Now, Jenna, I read, and you can tell me if this is true. I read that the first painting that they had for this episode to give to Meredith from Pam that they had one of our set art people who was a man do it. Yeah. And when they looked at it, it looked too masculine. Yeah. And so then they went out to female artists. That's a little bit of a softer touch. Yeah. And there was something
我觉得你太棒了。好吧，我喜欢我的那些富有表现力的漫画，但我需要并且希望帕姆是个比我更好的艺术家。所以有一个年轻的艺术生负责帕姆的所有画作。他们找了一群人，大约12位不同的艺术家来提交作品样本，以选出帕姆背后的那位艺术家。他们选中了一位年轻女性。现在，珍娜，我读到过，你可以告诉我这是不是真的。我读到过，他们为这一集准备的、要从帕姆送给梅雷迪思的第一幅画，是由我们的一个男性布景美术人员画的。对。当他们看到它时，觉得看起来太有男子气概了。对。所以他们后来去找了女艺术家。那是带有一点柔和触感的风格。对。当时有大约
like 12 different artists who all submitted their work. And I wish I knew her name. Unfortunately, I don't. But maybe I can find that out and reveal that in a future episode. And then so finally, two more gifts. Meredith got Dwight, some shot glasses from Cancun, and Kevin got himself a foot bath. Guys, around five minutes, 55 seconds, there is a scene where Michael is talking to Jim at Jim's desk. This is when he reveals that he got Ryan for Secret Santa. And I just want to say you see a ton of background action. Angela, you're walking from reception over Steve's shoulder. You see Toby and Mindy talking. Yeah. They are 100% not in character. Not in character at all. I saw that too. I was like, they're just talking about probably something in the writer's
12位不同的艺术家都提交了他们的作品。我希望我知道她的名字。不幸的是，我不知道。但也许我可以查到并在以后的节目中揭晓。然后最后，还有两份礼物。梅雷迪思送给德怀特一些来自坎昆的烈酒杯，凯文给自己买了一个足浴盆。伙计们，在大约五分五十五秒的时候，有一个场景是迈克尔在吉姆的桌子旁和吉姆说话。这就是他透露自己在神秘圣诞老人抽签里抽到了瑞恩的时候。我只想说，你能看到大量背景中的动作。安吉拉，你正从前台走过史蒂夫的肩膀。你能看到托比和明迪在聊天。对。他们百分之百没有在演角色。完全没有在演角色。我也看到了。我想，他们可能只是在聊编剧
room or a story pitch. Are they just having a conversation? Yeah. I mean, Paul is just being Paul. Yeah. If you anyone's curious, the difference between Toby and Paul go to five minutes, 55 seconds. Yeah. And you can see Paul and Mindy having a conversation in the background. Yeah, exactly. Tree lighting. Okay. I've been waiting for this moment. The Christmas tree lighting, this starts the beginning of Everyone Happy Angela Pist. So this Christmas tree, the top of it has been hacked off by Kevin. It is covered in so much tinsel. Yeah. So much tinsel. It has a smattering of just blue and red ball ornaments. It's just not their best effort. And then it has the tiniest of tiny white lights, thanks to Phyllis. So Dwight makes a big deal of it. He
室里的某件事或者某个故事创意。他们只是在进行一场对话吗？对。我是说，保罗只是在做他自己。对。如果有谁好奇，托比和保罗的区别在哪，去看五分五十五秒。对。你可以看到保罗和明迪在背景中聊天。对，没错。点亮圣诞树。好吧。我一直在等这一刻。圣诞树点灯，这拉开了“每个人都很开心，安吉拉气炸了”的序幕。所以这棵圣诞树，它的树顶被凯文砍掉了。上面挂满了金属饰带。对。挂了好多金属饰带。上面零星地点缀着一些蓝色和红色的球形装饰品。这真的不是他们发挥得最好的一次。然后它上面挂着菲莉丝功劳带来的极细极小的白灯。所以德怀特对此大惊小怪。他
like takes the, like the outlet, like the plug, what do you call it? The plug? The plug. He takes the plug from Stanley. He wants to plug it in. He's like, just like Rockefeller Center. And everyone gathers around and it's like, brrrrr. And Phyllis is like, I'm sorry. And at six minutes, 38 seconds, you see my first pissed off face. Dang it, Phyllis. It's also one of those moments where I feel like Angela is like, I knew it. I knew it. I knew I couldn't trust her. Why do I do these lights? Why do I even have her do anything? Why do you have anyone do anything? Yeah. You can't let anyone do anything. These people are worthless. Exactly. You know that Christmas tree light thing is based on a real thing from Mike Sharer's life. I know. He said that when
拿起了那个，就像电源插座，那个插头，你叫它什么？插头？插头。他从斯坦利手里拿过插头。他想把它插上。他说，就像洛克菲勒中心一样。大家聚拢过来，然后就是“呼啦”。菲莉丝说，我很抱歉。在六分三十八秒时，你看到了我第一张生气的脸。该死的，菲莉丝。这也是那些让我觉得安吉拉在想“我早就知道了”的时刻之一。我早就知道了。我早就知道我不能信任她。我为什么要做这些灯？我为什么还要让她做任何事？你为什么还要让任何人做任何事？对。你不能让任何人做任何事。这些人毫无价值。没错。你知道那棵圣诞树彩灯的点子是根据迈克·舒尔生活中的真实事情改编的吗。我知道。他说当
he and his wife got their first tree in New York, he bought a bunch of small lights for the tree and he wrapped them around and when he plugged it in, you couldn't really see them. I love that. I love when writers work those little moments from their real life into the show. I thought speaking about people who are acting like themselves instead of their characters, I thought Jim's talking head about Creed's gift is so John. It is John. That is John right there. Yeah. The delivery, the smile, all of it. And then of course, Creed's talking head made me laugh so hard. Creed is very funny in this episode. I mean, everybody has some great moments, but Creed cracked me up a bunch in this episode. So now Secret Santa is starting.
他和妻子在纽约买第一棵树时，他买了一大堆小灯挂在树上，当他把它插上电源时，你根本看不清它们。我太喜欢了。我喜欢编剧们把他们真实生活中的那些小瞬间写进节目里。我觉得说到那些做自己而不是扮演角色的演员时，吉姆关于克里德礼物的单人访谈太“约翰”了。这就是约翰。那简直就是约翰本人。对。那个语调，那个微笑，所有这一切。然后当然了，克里德的单人访谈让我笑得前仰后合。克里德这一集里非常搞笑。我是说，每个人都有一些高光时刻，但克里德这一集把我逗笑了好多次。所以现在神秘圣诞老人环节开始了。
Yep. And everyone is gathered around in some office chairs. And I want to say truly, I know we were joking about Charles McDougal, but the amount of energy and movement that he uses the camera to give this scene of people sitting in a circle. I mean, it is impressive from a directorial standpoint. I think like I don't want to be crazy, but I think like film students should study this portion of the episode because I'm imagining myself trying to film a group of people sitting in a circle doing a gift exchange and it would not look nearly this dynamic. It's really, really impressive directing. No, he's great. He is really great. Okay. So we're starting the Secret Santa and Pam opens Jim's teapot.
没错。大家都围坐在一些办公椅上。我想说的是，真的，我知道我们之前在开玩笑调侃查尔斯·麦克杜格尔，但他通过镜头为这个围坐成一圈交换礼物的场景所注入的能量和运镜。我是说，从导演的角度来看，这令人印象深刻。我觉得，我不是想显得疯狂，但我觉得电影系的学生应该研究这一集的这一部分，因为我在想象自己试图拍摄一群人围成一圈进行礼物交换，而它看起来绝不会有这么动态。这真的是，真的是非常棒的导演功力。不，他很棒。他真的很棒。好的。所以我们开始了神秘圣诞老人，帕姆打开了吉姆的茶壶。
She loves it, but Dwight moves things along so quickly that she doesn't have time to look inside or notice the card that's in the box. Yeah. Dwight wants no chitty chat between gifts. He's like, go, go, go, go. He's me coming in today. He is. He's like, save it for the mic. So he's moving things along. So it's Pam. And then the next one, we find out that Michael buys Ryan a video iPod that costs $400. You guys, this was not product placement. It was not. So many people wanted to know. Yeah. They, we were not paid. It was just sort of a really cool topical gift at the time. Yeah. And they were trying to think of a gift that would sort of be a showstopper that Michael would think was very impressive that everyone would want.
她很喜欢，但德怀特把节奏推得太快了，以至于她没有时间看里面或者注意到盒子里的卡片。对。德怀特不希望礼物之间有任何闲聊。他就像是，快，快，快，快。他就像今天的我。确实。他就像是在说，留着去麦克风那儿说吧。所以他在推进流程。所以是帕姆。然后下一个，我们发现迈克尔给瑞恩买了一个价值400美元的视频iPod。伙计们，这不是产品植入。真的不是。有太多人想知道了。对。他们，我们没有拿钱。这只是当时一个非常酷、非常应景的礼物。对。而且他们当时在想一个能够惊艳全场、迈克尔会觉得非常了不起并且所有人都会想要的礼物。
So this was coincidence. We weren't paid to use it. So I read that that well, well, here's the something. A ton of people wanted to know who kept it at the end. Nobody. We weren't allowed to keep any of the stuff. It all goes into a giant warehouse and it gets labeled for the episode for props because if for some reason we have to go back and reshoot something, they take it off the shelf and they bring it back in. That's true. I don't know what happens after it's been in the warehouse for a while, but it just goes to prop house storage. I feel like it's still in a box labeled the office Christmas party. Probably is. There was a fan question from beard up, beard down. Was the iPod sponsored by Apple? It wasn't. We said it was
所以这只是巧合。我们并没有收钱去用它。所以我听说，好吧，这里有个情况。一大群人想知道最后是谁留着它。没有人。我们不允许保留任何东西。它们都被送到一个巨大的仓库里，并贴上道具的剧集标签，因为如果出于某种原因我们必须回去重新拍摄什么，他们就会把它从架子上拿下来，然后再带回来。这是真的。我不知道它在仓库里待了一段时间后会怎么样，但它只是去了道具仓库。我觉得它仍然装在一个贴着办公室圣诞派对标签的箱子里。可能确实是。有一个来自“胡须向上，胡须向下”的粉丝问题：iPod是苹果赞助的吗？不是的。我们说过它
not. It's just a total coincidence, but there's more coincidence. So the week after this episode aired, Apple revealed that you could now download episodes of the office onto these video iPods. Again, this was not planned. And then the office became the number one downloaded show on iTunes. Yes. The number one downloaded show. I remember Rainn Wilson turned to me and said, I think we're going to make it. I think we're going to, this was the first moment it felt like the tide was turning for us and that we might not get canceled. All right. So next up, Michael gets his gift, the oven mitt knitted by Phyllis. Now everyone had a $20 limit, you guys. That's why this iPod really shakes everything up because he spent $400. Yes. Yes. And he has his line where
不是。这完全是个巧合，但还有更多的巧合。所以在这一集播出后的那一周，苹果透露你现在可以把《办公室》的剧集下载到这些视频iPod上了。再说一次，这不是计划好的。然后《办公室》成为了iTunes上下载量第一的节目。是的。下载量第一的节目。我记得雷恩·威尔逊转向我对我说，我想我们要成功了。我想我们要，这是第一个让人觉得风向正在对我们转变的时刻，我们可能不会被取消。好了。接下来，迈克尔得到了他的礼物，菲利斯织的烤箱手套。现在每个人都有20美元的限制，伙计们。这就是为什么这个iPod真的把一切都搞砸了，因为它花了400美元。是的。是的。他有他的台词，其中
he says I only, he says out in the hallway, he's holding the mitt and he says, do you know what this says? This says I only care about you a homemade oven mitts worth. He is such a child. He is such a bratty kid in this episode. Oh my gosh. Well, we had a fan question from Chelsea, Raccoza and Amanda and many others actually, who actually knitted the oven mitt? Well, I asked Phyllis, she does not knit in real life. Although she told me that she knitted a scarf for her mom a couple of years ago, but she said that's it. She didn't, oh, just one scarf. I want you guys to know, you know how we talk about what was at everyone's desk? So at Phyllis's desk, like sitting on the floor sort of next to her desk for so many years was a whole knitting basket. Do you
他说我只，他在走廊里说，他拿着手套说，你知道这说明什么吗？这说明我只在乎你一个自制烤箱手套的价值。他真是个孩子。这一集里他就像个被惯坏的孩子。哦天哪。好吧，我们有一个来自切尔西·拉科扎、阿曼达以及实际上许多其他人的粉丝问题：到底是谁织的烤箱手套？好吧，我问了菲利斯，她现实生活中不织毛织物。虽然她告诉我她几年前给她妈妈织过一条围巾，但她说仅此而已。她没有，哦，只织了一条围巾。我想让你们知道，你知道我们是怎么谈论每个人桌子上有什么的吗？所以在菲利斯的桌子上，像这样放在她桌子旁边地板上的，这么多年来一直是一个完整的毛线篮。你
remember? I do remember that. It had all the yarn and the knitting needles and it sat there as if her character would ever do anything with it, but it was established there and it sat there. Well, Phil Shea told me he found a woman at a knitting store in Valley Village, California and she knitted the oven mitt. Again, oven mitt knitter, if you're listening, please write us at officeladiesatearwolf.com and we'll give you a shout out. Yeah. Knitted the famous mitt. I thought it looked like a great oven mitt and it had like the little like a, like the Teflon. Teflon anythingy on the one side. Yeah. Yeah. So Ryan gets the iPod and at eight minutes, 24 seconds is the next phase of Angela Pistofness. Okay. You see my face at the fact that Michael spent $400
记得吗？我确实记得。里面有所有的纱线和织针，它就放在那里，仿佛她的角色会用它做任何事情，但它就是固定在那里，一直放在那里。好吧，菲尔·谢伊告诉我，他在加利福尼亚州山谷村的一家毛线店找到了一位女士，她织了这副烤箱手套。再次声明，烤箱手套的织造者，如果你在听，请给我们写信到officeladiesatearwolf.com，我们会给你一个大大的署名。是的。织了那副著名的手套。我觉得它看起来像个很棒的烤箱手套，而且它有一边有那种像特氟龙一样的东西。一侧有什么特氟龙东西。是的。是的。所以瑞恩得到了iPod，在8分24秒时，是安吉拉气急败坏的下一阶段。好吧。看到我对于迈克尔花了400美元的表情
when the limit was 20. All of my instructions, I'm sure I sent out an email about Secret Santa and the rules. So one, Phyllis has ignored my request for bigger lights and got the tiny lights. Now two, Michael has spent $400 instead of their agreed upon $20. So we're ramping up, she's getting ticked off. I have no doubt that you sent a very detailed email about this to everyone with a follow up reminder, which is why Kevin does not come forward when he gets himself because he would have had to tell me he would have. Yeah. You know what? I really relate to Angela on so many levels. Listen, really do. There's on some levels, you're way more Angela than I am. Oh yeah. I mean, I would have generated two, three, four very detailed emails about the
而限额是20美元。我所有的指示，我确信我发出了一封关于秘密圣诞老人和规则的电子邮件。所以第一，菲利斯忽略了我关于大灯的要求，拿来了小灯。现在第二，迈克尔花了400美元，而不是他们商定的20美元。所以我们要升级了，她开始生气了。毫无疑问，你给每个人都发了一封非常详细的电子邮件，并附有后续提醒，这就是为什么凯文在得到自己的东西时没有主动站出来，因为他必须告诉我，他会的。是的。你知道吗？我在很多方面都真的能跟安吉拉产生共鸣。听着，真的能。在某些方面，你比我更像安吉拉。哦，是的。我的意思是，我会为
party, the plans. If I assign someone to do lights for the tree and that's what I got, I would feel so pissed and let down. If people went over the $20 budget, you would have been furious. Furious. Because you would have been like, what's the point? Why even have that number? Is Angela wrong? No, I don't think she's wrong. She's just, you know, why is no one helping her? She's a buy the book person. Why can't people follow the rules? I agree. So at nine minutes, 39 seconds, she gets pissed off on a whole new level because as you were saying, this is when Michael is really ticked off that he got the oven mitt and he switches the party. No more secret, Santa. He says, now we're doing Yankee swap. Yes. Yankee swap slash white elephant slash,
派对和计划起草两份、三份、四份非常详细的电子邮件。如果我指派某人去给树装灯，而我得到的就是这个，我会感到非常生气和失望。如果人们超出了20美元的预算，你会气疯的。气疯的。因为你会觉得，有什么意义？为什么还要设那个数字？安吉拉错了吗？不，我不认为她错了。她只是，你知道，为什么没有人帮她？她是个按规矩办事的人。为什么人们就不能遵守规则？我同意。所以在9分39秒，她在一个全新的层面上被惹恼了，正如你所说，这是迈克尔对拿到烤箱手套真正感到恼火的时候，他把派对给换了。不再有秘密圣诞老人了。他说，现在我们玩洋基换宝。是的。洋基换宝斜杠白象斜杠，
what was the other one he said? Nasty Christmas. Nasty Christmas. You know, there was actually a little debate about what do you call it? And people were like, well, we call it white elephant. And someone else was like, we call it Yankee swap. And I feel like the writers took that and put it in the episode. Yeah, I know it as Yankee swap. What do you know? I knew it as white elephant. Yeah. I think it's good they did that. They covered everybody. They covered everybody. But when I threw my Christmas party, I called it Yankee swap just because I loved it so much. You know, here's something that I heard in the commentary, Angela, since we're talking about your character. I guess that you had a talking head in the fire. I watched it because I have a
另一个他怎么说来着？讨厌的圣诞节。讨厌的圣诞节。你知道，关于到底该叫它什么其实有过一点争论？人们会说，嗯，我们叫它白象。而另一些人则说，嗯，我们叫它洋基换宝。我觉得编剧们采纳了这一点并把它放进了剧集里。是的，我知道它叫洋基换宝。你知道什么？我知道它叫白象。是的。我觉得他们这么做挺好的。他们照顾到所有人了。他们照顾到所有人了。但当我举办圣诞派对时，我叫它洋基换宝，只是因为我太喜欢它了。你知道，安吉拉，既然我们在谈论你的角色，我在评论里听到了一点这样的消息。我猜你在火灾时有一段独白。我看了，因为我现在有
DVD player now. Where you cry. Yes, in the deleted scenes. Well, Mike said that the writer's room was so impressed with your performance and that talking head that they put a card on the wall that was Angela cries and they wanted to find an episode where you could cry a bunch. And this was it. Mike sure told me he said, I love to see your character cry. He said, she's so pulled together that when you sort of fall apart, it's like really sort of oddly pleasing. Oh, I love it. I love it. So yes, at nine minutes, 51 seconds, I have a talking head and my character is really upset because she feels like Michael should have talked to the PPC first. Yeah, well, they should have. And then she should have. And then she breaks down. So she is she is really starting to spiral.
DVD播放器。你在里面哭。是的，在被删减的片段里。迈克说编剧室对你的表现在那段独白中印象如此深刻，以至于他们在墙上贴了一张卡片，上面写着“安吉拉哭了”，他们想找一集你能大哭特哭的戏。而这就是这一集。迈克·舒尔告诉我，他说，我喜欢看你的角色哭。他说，她平时太镇定了，当你有点崩溃的时候，那感觉真的很奇怪地讨人喜欢。哦，我爱死这个了。我爱死这个了。所以是的，在9分51秒，我有一段独白，我的角色真的很沮丧，因为她觉得迈克尔应该先跟PPC谈谈。是的，嗯，他们本来应该的。然后她应该。然后她崩溃了。所以她，她真的开始失控了。
And then when we cut back to the scene, she's still sobbing. I mean, she's not sobbing, but she's still crying. She's sullen. She's very sullen. Okay, you know this famous line. Yankee swap. Yeah. From Michael. All right. Mike, sure. That's a written line that wasn't improvised that Steve would say Yankee swap. And Mike wrote in the script in parentheses, crazy voice. And he he was like, I know Steve will do something great with that. And that was Steve's take on that because they would do that. They would sometimes put little pieces of direction in the script for us and then we'd have to interpret it. Yeah. Guys, did you notice in this episode it is snowing outside? I loved this touch. I love that they
然后当我们切回这个场景时，她还在啜泣。我的意思是，她不是在啜泣，但她还在哭。她很郁闷。她非常郁闷。好了，你知道这句名言。洋基换宝。是的。来自迈克尔。好吧。迈克·舒尔。那是剧本里写好的台词，不是即兴发挥的，史蒂夫会说“洋基换宝”。迈克在剧本的括号里写了“疯狂的声音”。他就像是，我知道史蒂夫会用这个发挥得很棒。那是史蒂夫对那场戏的演绎，因为他们会那样做。他们有时会在剧本里为我们留下一点导演说明，然后我们不得不去演绎它。嘿，伙计们，你们注意到这一集外面在下雪吗？我太喜欢这个细节了。我喜欢他们
kept cutting to the windows and there'd be snow. Do you remember how much fun it was to have the snow? We were so tickled. We were snow. So excited. You guys remember we mostly just filmed inside and we never even saw outside or what was happening outside. Yeah. And so the fact that we had this extra element happening was so fun. We really did film inside in a windowless warehouse. All the windows were fake. They just had backdrops behind them. Yeah. So to see actual sunshine or snow or air was really exciting to us. I have a ton of facts about the snow. I don't know if anyone else will find it interesting, but I had written all about it in one of my blogs slash journals. I'm living for this. I can't wait to hear about it. All right. Do you have to pee?
一直切换到窗户的镜头，然后就会有雪。还记得下雪有多好玩吗？我们太高兴了。我们下雪了。好兴奋。你们还记得吗，我们大多只在室内拍摄，甚至从来看不到外面，或者外面发生了什么。是的。所以我们有这个额外的元素发生这一事实非常有趣。我们确实是在一个没有窗户的仓库里拍内景。所有的窗户都是假的。它们后面只是背景幕。是的。所以看到真正的阳光、雪或空气对我们来说真的令人兴奋。我有很多关于雪的事实。我不知道别人会不会觉得有趣，但我在我的一个博客/日记里写了关于它的所有事情。我太期待这个了。我迫不及待地想听听了。好了。你得去尿尿吗？
Oh, do you want me to give you some snow facts when we come back from the break? I mean, can I go pee? You should be on an empty bladder when I lay these awesome facts on you. You don't tell me or my bladder what we're doing. Well, what do you want? Do you want full bladder snow facts or empty bladder snow facts? I want empty bladder snow facts. All right. That's what I'm saying. Oh, I thought you were telling me that I had to not drink any more water or tea. When we go on a road trip, my husband will be like, can you not get a nice tea? Okay. Clearly you're projecting some other thing on me because I said I thought you should empty your bladder for the snow facts she's leaving. First, you push away from the mic to eat your snack.
哦，你希望我从休息回来时给你讲点关于雪的事实吗？我是说，我能去上个厕所吗？当我向你倾泻这些惊人的事实时，你的膀胱应该已经排空了。你别想告诉我或我的膀胱我们在做什么。好吧，你想要什么？你是想要满膀胱的雪的事实还是空膀胱的雪的事实？我想要空膀胱的雪的事实。好的。这就是我要说的。哦，我还以为你在告诉我，我不准再喝任何水或茶呢。当我们去公路旅行时，我丈夫会说，你不能不买好喝的茶吗？好吧。显然你在我身上投射了别的什么东西，因为我说过我觉得你应该为她要离开的雪的事实清空膀胱。首先，你把麦克风推开去吃零食。
This is for you, Jenna. So disgusting. Those are high-nut Cheerios. Oh, God. Thank you for letting me have my bathroom break. I want to hear all about your snow. All right. I hope this isn't anticlimactic for people, but the company that came to make the snow is called Snow Business. I love that. Snow business. Snow business. I remembered. I remembered that. It's so tickled me. Okay. So here's how it works with fake snow. There's a guy from snow business. He shows up. Now, the snow that falls from the sky is different from the ground cover snow. The snow on the ground is snow. The snow that falls from the sky, I know because it falls on my character at the end and it is not snow.
这是给你的，珍娜。太恶心了。那是全麦坚果甜圈圈。哦，天哪。谢谢你让我去上厕所。我想听听你关于雪的一切。好吧。我希望这对大家来说不是反高潮，但那家来造雪的公司叫雪之业务。我太喜欢这个了。雪之业务。雪之业务。我记住了。我记住了。这太让我高兴了。好了。所以假雪是这样运作的。有一个来自雪之业务的人。他出现了。现在，从天上落下的雪和地面覆盖的雪是不同的。地上的雪就是雪。从天上落下的雪，我知道，因为它最后落在了我的角色身上，那不是雪。
It's not snow. It's soap. Yes. You can get a choice. You can get a choice of cornstarch, plastic, or soap. And Greg watched a demonstration of all three and he picked soap. Well, when by accident, a little piece of that might get in your mouth. It tastes like soap because I shriek and I piece of it went in my mouth. That's what she said. Okay. On the ground, though, it's real snow and they bring this machine and I don't know exactly how it works, but it's kind of like a wood chipper, but in it in reverse. It looks like something out of a Dr. Seuss. It does. It really does. And it really blows snow. I guess that's what it looks like. It looks like a snowblower, but it generates snow.
那不是雪。那是肥皂。是的。你可以有一种选择。你可以选择玉米淀粉、塑料或肥皂。格雷格看了这三者的演示，他选择了肥皂。嗯，如果不小心，一小块那东西可能会进到你嘴里。它尝起来像肥皂，因为我尖叫了，有一小块进了我嘴里。那就是她说的。不过在地上，那是真的雪，他们带了这台机器，我不知道它具体是怎么运作的，但它有点像一台木材粉碎机，不过是反向的。它看起来像是苏斯博士书里的东西。确实如此。真的挺像。它真的能吹出雪。我想那就是它看起来的样子。它看起来像个吹雪机，但它能产生雪。
And then it just blows it all over the ground, all over the cars and all that stuff. But guys, remember, this is like, we're shooting this in like October in Los Angeles and it's hot in October. It stays warm here in the daytime. It's still in the mid eighties, nineties, but it was night. And so we had a little bit of time with it. I mean, it was still warm out. Yeah, it was probably like in the high sixties. Yeah. That sounds about right. All right. Yes. We were very excited to have snow and Jenna, we're, we're, did you like my snow facts? I feel a little vulnerable about them now because we set them up so much. I mean, there was like a break and then my head about it. I like your snow facts. Snow business. That's cute. I think
然后它就把它吹到整个地面上，所有的车上以及所有那些东西上。但是伙计们，记住，这就像，我们是在洛杉矶大约十月份拍摄的，十月份很热。这里白天依然很暖和。气温仍然在八十几度、九十几度，但那是晚上。所以我们有一点时间来处理它。我的意思是，外面还是挺暖和的。是的，大概有六十多度吧。是的，听起来差不多。好了。是的，有雪让我们非常兴奋，珍娜，我们，我们，你喜欢我的雪的事实吗？我现在对它们有点缺乏自信了，因为我们把它们铺垫得太久了。我的意思是，就像中间有个休息，然后是我关于它的头脑风暴。我喜欢你的雪的事实。雪之业务。这太可爱了。我觉得
snow business is really cute. All right. Let's go back to the gift exchange. This is when Kelly gets Angela's poster, but Angela, you do get to take it back. Okay. Here's the thing. I wrote in my space blog about this moment and I wrote that it was one of the hardest things for us to get through as a cast that the first time Mindy unrolls the poster and looks at it and we all see it. We all, every person lost it because it's so ridiculous. It's so ridiculous. We had not seen it. It was an actual surprise to us while we were filming and we all lost it. I had that in fact, it was particularly hard on rain for some reason and that in one take he broke three times because he could not get through it. I can't believe that Mindy was tasked with having to unroll
雪之业务真的很可爱。好了。让我们回到礼物交换环节。这是凯利拿到安吉拉海报的时候，但是安吉拉，你确实把它拿回来了。好吧。事情是这样的。我在我的太空博客里写过这个时刻，我写道，这是我们作为演员最难熬过去的时刻之一，当明迪第一次展开海报并看着它，我们所有人都看到了。我们所有人，每一个人都崩溃了，因为它太荒谬了。太荒谬了。我们之前没看过。我们在拍摄时这是一个真正的惊喜，我们全都崩溃了。事实上，不知为什么，这对雷恩来说尤其艰难，在一个镜头中他笑场了三次，因为他实在坚持不下去。我真不敢相信明迪的任务竟然是不得不展开
that poster. How did we ever get a shot of her not laughing? I don't know, but we were cracking up. There's a little detail in that scene that made me laugh when I rewatched it, which is how you, you just very subtly swat the oven midway on your way to getting the poster. That was all me. Thank you very much. I loved it. It was such a good detail. I loved it. Well, in tracking the oven mid, Meredith eventually takes the oven mid, but you know, Michael has to then call her a sucker and say that he wanted her to take it and it was reverse psychology when he said he wanted to keep it. I love that he decided that he needed to break down reverse psychology to all of us because I don't know if you've heard of it. This is a pretty cool thing. Michael, you're such an
那张海报。我们到底是怎么拍到她不笑的镜头的？我不知道，但我们当时都在放声大笑。那个场景里有一个小细节，当我重新观看时让我笑出来，那就是你在去拿海报的路上，非常微妙地拍打了一下烤箱手套。那全是我干的。非常感谢。我太喜欢了。这真是一个很好的细节。我很喜欢。好吧，在追踪烤箱手套的过程中，梅雷迪思最终拿走了烤箱手套，但你知道，迈克尔随后不得不叫她冤大头，并说他希望她拿走它，当他说他想留着它时，那是反向心理学。我喜欢他决定需要向我们所有人剖析反向心理学，因为我不知道你是否听说过这个。这是个挺酷的东西。迈克尔，你真是个
idiot. Do you remember how Phyllis cried during that scene? Yeah, she stayed in like sort of that sad place. She cried for like a half hour and in between takes of that where she had to be crying. She didn't want any of us to talk to her and Kate and I tried to go up and give her a hug. She didn't want it. Like she was in this like actor zone. It's so hard to do. It's so hard to do. I know exactly where she was, but I just remember being really worried for her because when you see Phyllis cry, it is, oh, you don't want to see Phyllis cry because it breaks every part of you open. I mean, she did, she wanted, she had to stay sad and it is really hard, especially sitting in this circle with people cracking up about a baby poster. Yeah, but you've
笨蛋。还记得菲利斯在那场戏里是怎么哭的吗？是的，她一直保持着那种悲伤的状态。她哭了大约半个小时，在必须哭泣的镜头间隙。她不想让我们任何人跟她说话，凯特和我试着过去给她一个拥抱。她不想要。就像她进入了这种演员状态一样。这太难做到了。这太难做到了。我确切地知道她在哪里，但我只记得真的很为她担心，因为当你看到菲利斯哭泣时，哦，你不会想看到菲利斯哭泣的，因为它会把你的每一部分都彻底撕裂。我的意思是，她确实想要，她必须保持悲伤，这真的很难，特别是当大家围坐在这个圈子里，为一个婴儿海报笑得前仰后合的时候。是的，但你
got to stay sad. Yes. It's hard. It's really hard. That is very difficult. Well, here's the thing. Michael just gets progressively meaner. You know, he calls Meredith a sucker and then Dwight, you know, he opens the paintball and he's like, you know, how is this better than an iPod? And this moment kind of broke my heart too. When Dwight goes, I never said it was better, you know. Hmm. Wait, I have an Angela pissed off in this moment. Okay, go at 13 minutes 58 seconds. Look at my face. I wrote it in all caps. So Michael has just called Meredith a sucker because she got the lame, you know, oven mitt and Phyllis storms out. Okay. Yeah. She was completely heartbroken now. And the party is falling apart. And the look on my face is just sheer in like rage.
得保持悲伤。是的。这很难。真的很难。那非常困难。好吧，事情是这样的。迈克尔只是变得越来越刻薄。你知道，他叫梅雷迪思冤大头，然后德怀特，你知道，他打开了彩弹枪，他说，你知道，这怎么能比iPod更好？这个时刻也让我有点心碎。当德怀特说，我从来没说它更好，你知道。嗯。等等，我在这个时刻有一个“安吉拉气急败坏”。好的，在13分58秒。看我的脸。我用全大写字母写了。所以迈克尔刚刚叫梅雷迪思冤大头，因为她拿到了那个糟糕的烤箱手套，而菲利斯冲了出去。好吧。是的。她现在完全心碎了。派对正在分崩离析。我脸上的表情纯粹是愤怒。
Now, are we at the top of your rage now? No. Oh, no. Well, I mean, I know we've still got the parking lot, but no, oh, no, there's a moment coming and you'll know it. It's the there's, there's a one two punch coming at the end for my anger. But yeah. All right. So people are making trades and feelings are getting hurt. Yeah. And Pam does not go back and get the teapot. She gets the iPod. She does. When it's Pam's turn to pick again, she picks the iPod instead of the teapot and Jim is so hurt. He's so hurt. And I, you know, I watched this and I was like, come on, Pam. But then, you know, Pam doesn't know what all is in the teapot. She doesn't. And that's what sort of justified it for me. She's just like, this is an iPod. This iPod has completely hijacked this whole
现在，我们达到你愤怒的顶点了吗？没有。哦，不。好吧，我的意思是，我知道我们还有停车场那场戏，但是没有，哦，没有，有一个时刻就要来了，你会认出来的。在最后，我的愤怒将迎来一套组合拳。但是，是的。好了。所以人们在做交易，感情受到了伤害。是的。而且帕姆没有回去拿茶壶。她拿了iPod。她确实拿了。当轮到帕姆再次挑选时，她选了iPod而不是茶壶，吉姆太受伤了。他太受伤了。而且我，你知道，我看了这个，然后我想，拜托，帕姆。但随后，你知道，帕姆并不知道茶壶里有什么。她不知道。这就是为我辩解的地方。她只是觉得，这是一个iPod。这个iPod彻底劫持了
fun party and gift exchange because everybody who's sitting in the seat is just thinking about trying to get this iPod. And so is Pam. Unfortunately, I think she kind of forgot about the teapot. So it was her time to pick. She was just like, iPod. But she also doesn't know what's in the teapot. She doesn't know how high the stakes are for Jim. No, she doesn't. I think it's kind of an innocent moment, honestly. And Michael has ruined all of this because the gifts were specific for people. I mean, Ryan gets a placard that says Kelly. Yeah. He gets like, you know, a desk, whatever name plate. Yeah. Like these were not meant to be Yankee swap gifts. They were not. They were meant for certain people. Well, at this point, the party has completely broken down.
整个有趣的派对和礼物交换，因为每个坐在座位上的人都在想着试图得到这个iPod。帕姆也是。不幸的是，我想她有点把茶壶给忘了。所以轮到她挑选了。她当时就想：iPod。但她也不知道茶壶里有什么。她不知道这对外面的吉姆来说赌注有多高。不，她不知道。老实说，我认为这只是一个无辜的时刻。迈克尔把这一切都毁了，因为这些礼物都是为特定的人准备的。我的意思是，瑞恩得到了一块写着“凯利”的铭牌。是的。他得到了一个，你知道的，办公桌名牌之类的东西。是的。这些本来不是用来做洋基换宝礼物的。它们不是。它们是为某些人准备的。好吧，在这个时候，派对已经彻底崩溃了。
And Michael goes to the liquor store. Now, I want to point out a few things. I know what you're going to point out because lady, I have the DVDs now. So go do it. Do you know what I'm going to say? Is it about the attendant at the liquor store? I have one thing to say about him. But I just thought I wanted to point out that it's also snowing outside the window of the liquor store. Yeah. They made it snow there too. I don't know. Nice detail. Nice touch. Good continuity. Veda was on it. Well, I read that our writers found out in Pennsylvania that if you work at a liquor store, you have to wear a tie. Yes. And so that was part of this character description is that he had to have on a tie. Isn't that great? And I thought the actor, his name is Ryan Martin, did a fantastic
然后迈克尔去了酒类商店。现在，我想指出几件事。我知道你要指出什么，因为女士，我现在有DVD了。所以说吧。你知道我要说什么吗？是关于酒类商店的服务员吗？我有一件事要说。但我只是觉得我想指出，酒类商店窗外也在下雪。是的。他们在那里也造了雪。我不确定。不错的细节。不错的点缀。良好的连贯性。韦达很在行。好吧，我读到我们的编剧在宾夕法尼亚州发现，如果你在酒类商店工作，你必须系领带。是的。所以那是这个角色描述的一部分，他必须系着领带。这不是很棒吗？我觉得那个演员，他的名字叫瑞安·马丁，表现得
job. He just really like takes in all of that vodka and it's just 15 bottles. 15 bottles. Craziness. Okay. So then we go back to the party. Michael brings all this vodka back into the party and it's 16, 10 minutes. This is the next phase of Angela's spiral. Oh, say it. So Michael has vodka and she's like, what are you doing? There's no alcohol at the party. You know, Angela speaks up and Toby speaks up. No one else cares. But now she's Toby speaks up. I missed that. Yeah. Toby's like, Michael, we really shouldn't have any goes. Just shut it, Toby. It's a party. But then later, I feel like Toby brings Todd Packer a drink. Well, no, it's all, all like all that's off. And, and you know, you have to remember that Michael told the party planning
棒极了。他只是把所有的伏特加都买下了，整整15瓶。15瓶。太疯狂了。好了。然后我们回到派对。迈克尔把所有这些伏特加带回了派对，时间是16分10秒。这是安吉拉情绪失控的下一阶段。哦，说吧。所以迈克尔有伏特加，而她就像，你在干什么？派对上没有酒精。你知道，安吉拉大声抗议，托比也大声抗议。没有人在乎。但现在她站出来了。托比站出来了。我错过了。是的。托比说，迈克尔，我们真的不应该有任何去。闭嘴吧，托比。这是个派对。但后来，我觉得托比给托德·帕克尔带了一杯饮料。好吧，不，一切都，都像一切都失控了。而且，你知道，你必须记住，迈克尔告诉派对策划
committee that he wanted this Christmas party to be like, and I quote, a playboy mansion party. Yeah. That was his hope. That's his goal. That's his goal. So but yeah, Angela is now super ticked because now there's alcohol. I'm surprised her whole head didn't explode. Well, it's about to because the next two are what set it set it into motion. Oh boy. Well, now we have the scene where Jim is trying to get the teapot back from Dwight. Jim offers to trade him the shamrock keychain and he says, come on, it'll be good luck. And that's when Dwight has his line. A real man makes his own luck. Billy Zane, Titanic and Angela, you made the entire cast t-shirts with that quote on them. And I still have mine. Oh my gosh, you do. I do. It's a gray,
委员会，他希望这个圣诞节派对就像，我引用一下，“花花公子庄园派对”。是的。那是他的希望。那是他的目标。那是他的目标。所以，但是，是的，安吉拉现在超级生气，因为现在有了酒精。我很惊讶她的整个脑袋没有炸掉。好吧，它快要炸了，因为接下来这两个才是点燃导火索的导火索。哦，天哪。好吧，现在我们有了吉姆试图从德怀特那里要回茶壶的戏。吉姆提出用三叶草钥匙扣跟他交换，他说，得了吧，这会带来好运的。然后德怀特说出了那句台词。真正的硬汉靠自己创造运气。比利·赞恩，《泰坦尼克号》。安吉拉，你给整个剧组制作了印有这句名言的T恤。我还留着我的呢。哦天哪，你还留着。我留着。那是一件灰色、
long sleeve t-shirt. Yes. And it's just a quote across it. Yeah. So I had a friend at the time who had a t-shirt press because she had a small business. And I loved this line so much. I thought I thought it was hilarious of all people for Dwight to quote. It would be Billy Zane. Well, people were asking if we gave each other gifts. That was a gift. You gave that out. I think you actually gave that out at Christmas that year. I did. And you gave everyone an ornament. Yes. I got that cast photo and I had it printed on an ornament for everyone. Yeah. Oh, the idea that Dwight wants to keep the teapot in order to wash out his nasal passages with green tea is based on something that Greg Daniels has actually done. Like with a neti pot? Yeah, I mean, but I've never
长袖T恤。是的。上面就印着一句话。是的。所以当时我有一个朋友有一台T恤印花机，因为她有自己的小生意。我太喜欢这句台词了。我觉得由德怀特说出这样的话，在所有人当中简直太搞笑了。那会是比利·赞恩。好吧，人们一直在问我们是否互赠礼物。那是件礼物。你把它发出去了。我想你那年圣诞节真的把那个发出去了。我发了。而且你送了每个人一个装饰品。是的。我拿到了那张演员合影，并把它印在一个装饰品上送给了每个人。是的。哦，德怀特为了用绿茶清洗鼻腔而想要留着茶壶的想法，是基于格雷格·丹尼尔斯实际做过的事情。就像用洗鼻壶那样？是的，我的意思是，但我从来没有
put green tea in a neti pot. I haven't either. I've only used the saline solution that is recommended. But I could see Greg reading about it and giving it a try. But rain, the way rain was in that scene. And then he like shoved that teapot into his nostril. Yeah. And just John's face is Jim is just like, are you kidding me? That that's who gets my teapot. Like it's so perfect. He's so bummed. Now, when I watched this with Lee, Lee said he wondered how Dwight didn't find the note in the box or how Dwight didn't open up the teapot. I thought of all of those things. I thought Dwight now has the cassette and the sauce packet. I mean, so you have to sort of suspend belief, I guess, at that moment that that he took those out and just shoved
在洗鼻壶里放过绿茶。我也没有。我只用过推荐的盐水溶液。但我能想象格雷格读到过这个并尝试了一下。但是雷恩，雷恩在那场戏里的状态。然后他把那个茶壶塞进鼻孔里。是的。然后吉姆的表情就像是，你在开玩笑吗？这就是得到我茶壶的人？太完美了。他太沮丧了。现在，当我跟李一起看这个时，李说他很好奇德怀特怎么没在盒子里找到便条，或者德怀特怎么没打开茶壶。我想到了所有这些事情。我想德怀特现在有了磁带和酱汁包。我的意思是，所以你必须在某种程度上暂停信念，我想，在那一刻，他把那些拿出来然后直接塞了进去
him aside like, hmm, what's this crap? And just sort of shoved him aside in the box. Well, also, I don't think Jim is trying to get the teapot back for Pam. I think he's just trying to get the teapot back for himself. He's just going to keep it now. That's what I think the motivation is there because Pam is over, you know, up at the desk with Roy looking through her new iPod. I think Jim just wants to get it back because I think there's things inside it that are embarrassing. Yes, exactly. But he's going to trade the key chain and he's just going to take that teapot home now. So Pam is up at reception and she's showing Roy her new iPod. He's now at the party. He wasn't there for Yankee Swap, but he's all excited because now he doesn't have to buy it
把他放到一边，就像是，嗯，这是什么垃圾？然后顺手把他扔在盒子里。而且，我觉得吉姆也不是为了潘才去把茶壶拿回来的。我觉得他只是为了自己才把茶壶拿回来的。他现在打算把它据为己有了。我觉得这就是他当时的动机，因为潘正和罗伊一起站在桌子旁看她的新iPod。我觉得吉姆只是想把它拿回来，因为我觉得里面有些东西很尴尬。是的，完全正确。但他打算用钥匙链换，然后现在就把那个茶壶带回家。所以潘在接待处，她正在向罗伊展示她的新iPod。他现在来参加派对。他刚才没参加白象交换礼物，但他现在非常兴奋，因为他现在不用买了
for Pam for Christmas. He was going to buy her this iPod, he tells her, and now he doesn't have to where he's just going to get her a sweater. Thanks, Roy. Now the party is like 15 bottles of vodka in. Todd Packer has showed up. Oh yeah. It's getting crazy. And everyone's doing shots. Angela's fuming. I am fuming, but the icing on the cake of my pissed-offness is about to happen. Oh, say it. Michael shouts to the whole bullpen. He says, oh my gosh, yes, Ryan, the king of the party planning. Oh, thank you to Ryan for this awesome party. And the camera pans to me and I am livid. Ryan, the temp, the king of the party planning committee. Are you kidding me? Yeah. Oh, that's it. She is pissed. Oh no. And it's only going to get worse. That's not even still the
圣诞节给潘的礼物了。他本来要给她买这个iPod的，他告诉她，现在他不用买了，他打算只给她买件毛衣。谢谢你，罗伊。现在派对已经喝掉了大约15瓶伏特加。托德·帕克出现了。哦，天哪。情况开始疯狂了。每个人都在干杯。安吉拉气炸了。我气炸了，但我那个愤怒值达到顶点的时刻即将到来。哦，快说吧。迈克尔向整个办公区大喊。他说，哦天哪，太棒了，瑞安，派对策划之王。哦，感谢瑞安举办了这个棒极了的派对。镜头摇向我，我气得脸色铁青。瑞安，那个临时工，派对策划委员会之王？你在开玩笑吗？是的。哦，就是这样。她气疯了。哦，不。而且情况只会变得更糟。这甚至还不是
worst thing that's happened to Angela. Nope. I had a headache by the end of this episode. You must have. You were just scowling and pushing anger out of your temples this whole episode. You know when Todd Packer shows up and he has that line, what's up, my nerds? My nerds. That was an improv sort of. In the script, what was written was what's up, nerds. And he just gave it that extra special touch of what's up, my nerds. I know. Well, that's also Dave Keckner. I mean, I think even the line when he's like, Packer need a drinky. Yeah. The line was probably like, he was getting me a drink. Yeah. You know, he brought so much to that role. It was amazing. And well, you know, when he has to lay down on the desk and get the silly string on him, like when he passes out,
安吉拉遇到的最糟糕的事情。不。这集结束时我都头疼了。你肯定头疼。你整集都在板着脸，太阳穴直冒火气。你知道当托德·帕克出现时，他有那句台词，我的书呆子们，最近怎么样？我的书呆子们。那有点是即兴发挥。剧本里写的是，书呆子们，最近怎么样。而他特意加了那个特别的温情触碰，我的书呆子们，最近怎么样。我知道。嗯，这也是戴夫·科克纳的风格。我是说，甚至当他说，帕克需要一杯饮料吗？是的。那句台词可能就像，他要给我拿杯饮料。是的。你知道，他为那个角色注入了太多东西。这太棒了。而且，你知道，当他不得不躺在桌子上，身上沾满彩色喷条时，就像他晕倒的时候，
I remember shooting that he had to lay there forever. So he laid down on those desks, which were not comfortable, right? And then they silly stringed his head. And then we had all these scenes where that's what he's doing. Well, if he got up, all the stuff that he was decorated in would have fallen off, it would have been impossible to recreate. So he had to just lay there, even when we were on a break, even when we were on a break. And he was such a trooper. Talk about a trooper. And I wrote in my MySpace blog that Kate and I, because Kate and I knew Dave from Improv Days, we had all like done improv shows together, that Kate and I walked over and talked to him while he had to lay on his back. And we just sort of like caught up and that it was so
我记得拍那一幕时，他得在上面躺好久。所以他躺在那些桌子上，一点也不舒服，对吧？然后他们把彩色喷条喷在他的头上。接着我们拍了所有这些场景，他都得保持那个姿势。好吧，如果他站起来，他身上那些装饰的东西就会掉下来，那就绝对没办法重新布置了。所以他只能躺在那里，即使我们在休息时，即使我们在休息时也是如此。他太敬业了。说他是模范真是一点不为过。我在我的MySpace博客里写过，凯特和我，因为凯特和我从即兴表演时期就认识戴夫了，我们一起做过很多即兴表演秀，凯特和我走过去跟他说话，当时他还得躺在背上。我们就在那儿叙旧，能见到他真的
fun to see him. But I want you guys to know, if you're wondering what Todd Packer looks like at 20 minutes, 19 seconds, to really paint a picture here. He's laying on his back kind of across a desk area partition, right in the middle of the room. He has blue silly string on his head, Christmas lights around his torso, Christmas garland around his torso, Dwight's desk name plate on his stomach. And there's like a red empty solo cup kind of just like in his like the crook of his arm. And he had to lay like that with all those things on top of him. He passes out so quickly. You have to imagine he showed up already half drunk. You know he did. You know he did. You know he did. Okay guys, so now we have the scene
太开心了。但我想让你们知道，如果你好奇托德·帕克在20分19秒时是什么样子，让我来勾勒一下画面。他仰面躺在办公桌区域的隔板上，就在房间正中央。他的头上挂着蓝色的彩色喷条，躯干上缠着圣诞彩灯，躯干上缠着圣诞花环，肚子上放着德怀特的桌上名牌。还有一个红色的空塑料红杯，就夹在他的臂弯里。他必须以那种姿势躺着，身上压着所有这些东西。他晕倒得太快了。你不得不想象他出现时已经喝了半醉。你知道他就是这样。你知道他就是。你知道他就是。好了，各位，现在我们来到这个场景
where Pam reveals to Jim that she got her teapot back. She trades Dwight the iPod for the teapot, and now she's going to look inside and find all the items. And it's very charming and sweet and she is so delighted. But in this moment, Jim secretly steals the note back and puts it in his pocket. I know. He lost his courage. He did. Now, when we reached out to fans to ask them what they wanted to know about the Christmas episode, I would say that about 80% of the comments and emails we received were along the lines of what is in the teapot note. Because as you know, in this episode, Pam does not read it. It is not revealed. But then in season nine, there's a scene where Jim has the documentary film crew put together footage
潘向吉姆透露她把茶壶拿回来了。她用iPod跟德怀特交换了茶壶，现在她要看里面并找到所有的东西。这非常迷人且甜蜜，她高兴极了。但在这一刻，吉姆偷偷把纸条拿了回来，塞进了自己的口袋。我知道。他失去了勇气。他确实是。现在，当我们联系粉丝询问他们想了解关于圣诞节这集的什么内容时，我想说，我们收到的评论和电子邮件中，大约有80%都围绕着茶壶里的纸条上写了什么。因为正如你们所知，在这集中，潘并没有读它。并没有被揭晓。但在第九季中，有一个场景，吉姆让纪录片摄制组把他们恋爱的片段剪辑
of their romance and he shows it to Pam. And Pam sees that there was a note that Jim steals back and then he hands it to her and she reads it. How brilliant is that? And you know who that is. That's Greg Daniels. Yeah. Because he was such a master at beautiful callback moments. I love that. Well, from the time that Jim stole the note, it drove people crazy. They always wanted to know what had been written in the note. Would Pam ever get the note? For years and years, will he ever give her the note? Around the time of the wedding, people wanted him to give it to her as a wedding gift. Greg saved it till the end. I'm going to say something that I've never said before. I also feel like I'm maybe going to cry. What? Wait. Wait. What? Are you going to
到一起，然后他把它放给潘看。潘看到里面有一张纸条是吉姆偷回来的，然后他把它递给她，她读了。这有多绝妙？你们知道那是谁的主意吗。那是格雷格·丹尼尔斯。是的。因为他是那种绝妙的回忆时刻的大师。我太喜欢了。好吧，从吉姆偷走纸条的那一刻起，人们就快疯了。他们总是想知道纸条上写了什么。潘会读到这张纸条吗？年复一年，他到底会不会把纸条给她？在婚礼前后，人们希望他把它作为结婚礼物送给她。格雷格把它留到了最后。我要说一件我从未说过的事。我也觉得我可能要哭了。什么？等等。等等。什么？你打算
say what was in the note? Are you going to say what was in the note? Sort of. Because I don't know what was on that card. None of us do. I'm the only one who knows and John knows. Oh my gosh, lady. In that episode in season nine, I believe Greg suggested to John that he write a personal message from himself to me, just saying what our time together on the office meant to him. Because we were wrapping up filming, we were wrapping up the series and we were all so emotional at that time, you know? We were all sort of saying goodbye in different ways. We were. And so that was his goodbye. Very similar to when we filmed that scene with Steve, where I said goodbye
说纸条里写了什么吗？你打算说纸条里写了什么吗？算是吧。因为我不知道那张卡片上写了什么。我们都不知道。只有我知道，还有约翰知道。哦天哪，蕾迪。在第九季的那集中，我相信格雷格建议约翰给我写一条他自己的私人信息，只是表达我们在办公室一起度过的时光对他意味着什么。因为我们要结束拍摄了，我们要结束这个系列了，那时我们所有人都百感交集，你知道吗？我们都在以不同的方式告别。我们确实是。所以那是他的告别。非常类似于我们和史蒂夫拍的那场戏，我在机场向他告别
to him at the airport and Paul Feig told me, just run up and say goodbye to your friend, Steve. Jeff Blitz said the same thing to me when I was in the car with Oscar. And I say I loved Dwight. He said, Angela, in this moment, express your love for the show and everyone and if you couldn't have it in your life anymore. And I disintegrated. Yeah. So I'm on camera and I open up this note that John's written me and I just start crying. I just start bawling. Probably the first take was probably not usable. It was the sweetest note. And you know, on camera, Pam says, I'll never say what it said, but just know it was perfect. Well, I'll never say exactly what John wrote, but I will say just know it was perfect.
，保罗·费格告诉我，跑过去向你的朋友史蒂夫告别吧。杰夫·布里茨在我跟奥斯卡在车里时也说了同样的话。我说我爱德怀特。他说，安吉拉，在这个时刻，表达你对这个节目和每个人的爱，就好像你的生活里再也没有它了一样。然后我情绪崩溃了。是的。所以我开着镜头，打开约翰写给我的这张纸条，我开始哭泣。我开始放声大哭。可能第一个镜头根本没法用。那是极其温暖的纸条。而且，你知道，在镜头前，潘说，我永远不会说上面写了什么，但只要知道那是完美的。好吧，我永远不会说约翰到底写了什么，但我会说，只要知道那是完美的就行。
So that's what was in the teapot note, guys. It was a note from John to me. A personal note about what it meant to work with you on the show. Yeah. Yeah. About our time together on the show, and it was really sweet. Well, that would completely wreck me. Yeah. Oh, I love that. I didn't know that. Are you okay? Yeah. Well, crap. How do we talk about anything else that was so beautiful?
所以这就是茶壶纸条里的内容，各位。那是约翰写给我的纸条。一张关于在节目中与你共事意味着什么的个人纸条。是的。是的。关于我们一起在节目中度过的时光，真的非常温暖。好吧，这会彻底把我击垮。是的。哦，我太喜欢了。我之前不知道。你还好吗？是的。好吧，真见鬼。我们怎么还能聊其他这么美好的事？
I'm sorry. That was so beautiful. I love that that was the direction that Greg gave. Those moments became very honest for us under that kind of direction. Yeah. And we all had little moments like that. That's a really big one, though. Well, there were those moments on the show that were surprises. Yeah. Steve didn't know I was going to run up and tell him that basically that same thing, Steve,
我很抱歉。那真的太美好了。我太喜欢格雷格给出的那个指导了。在那种指导下，那些时刻对我们来说变得非常真实。是的。我们每个人都有过那种小小的时刻。不过那真是一个非常重大的时刻。好吧，节目中确实有那些充满惊喜的时刻。是的。史蒂夫不知道我要跑过去告诉他基本上同样的话，史蒂夫，
I'm going to miss you, you know, all the things that I said to him. Oscar didn't know the note that Jeff Blitz gave me. Yeah. So when all that emotion came, it was very like completely out of nowhere for him. Yeah. Okay. Well, geez, Louise. I'm sorry. That's okay. Where are we at in this episode?
我会想念你的，你知道的，所有我对他说过的话。奥斯卡不知道杰夫·布里茨给我的那张纸条。是的。所以当所有那些情感涌现时，对他来说完全是始料未及的。是的。好吧，天哪。我很抱歉。没关系。我们这集进行到哪儿了？
Well, we're at the moment when Kelly approaches Dwight in the kitchen. Kelly, that hussy. Oh, with her hair half down, half up. I know. She goes up to my man and lays one on him. She does. And Angela sees it and that is it. You know, a lot of people wrote in and commented that you're standing in front of a poster that says commitment.
好吧，我们到了凯利在厨房接近德怀特的时刻。凯利那个风骚的女人。哦，她的头发半披半扎。我知道。她走到我的男人面前，吻了他一下。她确实这么做了。安吉拉看到了，这就够了。你知道，很多人写信和留言说你正站在一张写着承诺的海报前面。
Am I really? Yes. Oh my gosh, I didn't even notice. That is so funny. I think I was just so focused on the scene. Yeah. Wow. Yes. Angela loses it.
我真的吗？是的。哦天哪，我甚至都没注意到。太搞笑了。我想我当时太专注于这场戏了。是的。哇。是的。安吉拉气急败坏了。
Loses it. And this takes us outside. She's left the party and now I have some stuff to tell you guys about the scene. Oh, yeah. All right. 20 minutes, 16 seconds. The ultimate Angela pissed offness has happened. So here's some behind the scenes of this scene.
气急败坏。这把我们带到了外面。她离开了派对，现在我有些关于这场戏的事要告诉你们。哦，是的。好吧，20分16秒。终极愤怒的安吉拉诞生了。所以这里有一些这场戏的幕后花絮。
You have a guy up on the roof and he's got the soap snow. Yep. That he's going to fall into your eyes. He's going to, yeah, stinging. And then there's snow on the ground because they've put real snow on the ground. We filmed this scene at the end of the day and everyone had gone. It was just me and Charles McDougal, Randall Einhorn and Mike Schurr. So it was just a kind of a skeleton crew at this point.
你看到屋顶上有个家伙拿着肥皂雪。是的。那玩意儿会掉进你的眼睛里。它会，是的，刺痛。然后地上有雪，因为他们在地上铺了真雪。我们在一天结束时拍摄了这场戏，所有人都走了。只有我和查尔斯·麦克杜格尔、兰德尔·艾因霍恩以及迈克尔·舒尔。所以当时基本上只剩一个精简的摄制组了。
Those are always some of my most favorite shoots. Yeah, me too. And we did not have a lot of time. We didn't have a lot of time to get this. The clock was ticking. Yeah, exactly. Because we didn't want to go into overtime for everyone and it was the end of the day. And so Charles McDougal said to me, we're probably only going to do like two takes,
那些一直是我最喜欢的拍摄经历。是的，我也是。而且我们没有太多时间。我们没有太多时间来完成这个。时间在流逝。是的，正好。因为我们不想让每个人都加班，而且已经是天黑收工的时候了。所以查尔斯·麦克杜格尔对我说，我们大概只拍两遍，
you know, maybe three, but they gave me these ornaments. And my instruction was that my character has just lost it. Michael has ruined Christmas. Kelly has kissed my man. Ryan is the king of the party planning committee. Right? Yes. He said, I want you to take these ornaments and just throw them and shatter them.
你知道，也许三遍，但他给了我这些装饰品。给我的指令是我的角色刚刚崩溃了。迈克尔毁了圣诞节。凯利吻了我的男人。瑞安是派对策划委员会之王。对吧？是的。他说，我要你拿着这些装饰品，然后把它们扔掉并砸碎。
They were written in the script as glass ornaments. They were not glass ornaments. What? Watch the scene. I throw them down. They bounce straight up in the air. What were they? They were like some kind of plastic composite, whatever.
剧本里写的是玻璃装饰品。它们根本不是玻璃装饰品。什么？看这场戏。我把它们扔下去。它们直接弹向空中。那是什么东西？它们是某种塑料复合材料之类的东西。
Oh, no. So when you look, watch it, you guys, you see them bounce in the air. I assumed, well, that makes sense. We did not have the budget to get special breakaway glass ornaments, and there's no way they would give you real glass. No. So these things bounced like a tennis ball. And so Charles is like, cut.
哦，不。所以当你看的时候，你们看，你看到它们在空中弹起。我以为，好吧，这说得通。我们没有预算去买专门的易碎玻璃装饰品，而且他们绝不可能给你真玻璃。不。所以这东西像网球一样弹了起来。所以查尔斯就喊，咔。
And he goes, okay, two things. One, we need you to stand closer to the wall. Like if you can in the scene, get as close to the wall as possible, because that's where the guy is with the soap coming down. Yeah. The soap doesn't fall very far. So yeah. We have another take, and he's like,
然后他说，好吧，两件事。第一，我们需要你站得离墙更近一点。如果可以的话，在戏里尽量靠近墙壁，因为那是喷肥皂泡沫的人所在的位置。是的。肥皂泡沫飞不了太远。所以，是的。我们再拍一条，他说，
why aren't you breaking the ornaments? I'm like, Charles, they're bouncing. What are you talking about? He goes, can you throw them harder? I was like, yeah, they're just going to bounce higher. And I was like, okay, I got it. I got it. I have an idea.
你为什么不把装饰品砸碎？我说，查尔斯，它们在弹跳。你在说什么？他说，你能用力扔吗？我说，可以，它们只会弹得更高。然后我说，好吧，我明白了。我明白了。我有个主意。
So I know now we're really running out of time. And Michael Gallenberg had taken the most awesome photo that I have, and it's the snow falling and me throwing the ornaments, and Charles McDougall in the distance watching me. Oh, cool. That's great. Michael Gallenberg, our set designer. Yeah, he took this photo.
所以我知道现在我们的时间真的不多了。迈克尔·加伦伯格拍了一张我拥有的最棒的照片，那是雪花飘落，我正在扔装饰品，而查尔斯·麦克杜格尔在远处看着我。哦，酷。太棒了。迈克尔·加伦伯格，我们的布景设计师。是的，他拍了这张照片。
It was so cool. But anyway, here I am. We're running out of time. I got to stand. I got to get myself to the wall. I got to throw these ornaments, and I need them to break. And I have to shriek, right? So I throw them with, I said, I'm going to throw them harder this time.
太酷了。但不管怎样，我在这儿。时间不多了。我得站好。我得把自己挪到墙边。我得扔这些装饰品，我需要它们碎掉。而且我还得尖叫，对吧？所以我用，我说，我这次要用力扔它们。
I don't know. So I threw them as hard as I could. They bounced up higher. I shrieked, and I just started stomping on them and shattering them with my feet. Was that your intention going in when you're like, I have an idea. I can do it. I can do it.
不知道。所以我用尽全力把它们扔了出去。它们弹得更高了。我尖叫起来，然后开始用脚踩它们，把它们踩得粉碎。你进去的时候是有这个打算的吗，就好像，我有个主意。我能做到。我能做到。
I was thinking, if I can't get them to break, I have to start stomping on them. Yes. So that's what I just did. That was just an improv in the moment. I just started stomping on them. Folks, notice I'm wearing my sass shoes. Oh, that's the perfect shoe for this.
I was thinking, if I can't get them to break, I have to start stomping on them. Yes. So that's what I just did. That was just an improv in the moment. I just started stomping on them. Folks, notice I'm wearing my sass shoes. Oh, that's the perfect shoe for this.|||我在想，如果我没办法让他们笑场，我就得开始狂踩它们。是的。所以我刚才就是这么做的。那只是当时的即兴发挥。我开始狂踩它们。各位，注意看我穿着我的时髦鞋。哦，这鞋简直太适合了。
I know. And so I shriek, I get to the wall. I'm stomping things. I rip the box apart. We got the scene. Oh, let me tell you, ToneLoke89 is going to be very happy because they wrote in with a fan question. What was that?
I know. And so I shriek, I get to the wall. I'm stomping things. I rip the box apart. We got the scene. Oh, let me tell you, ToneLoke89 is going to be very happy because they wrote in with a fan question. What was that?|||我懂。然后我尖叫着冲到墙边。我狂踩东西。我把盒子撕碎。这场戏就成了。哦，我跟你说，ToneLoke89一定会很高兴，因为他们发来了一个粉丝提问。是什么？
One of my favorite scenes is when Angela screams and smashes the glass ornaments. What was it like to film? All of that. Yes, exactly. But now if you go back and watch the scene, you guys, watch the first two that I throw. I think that's kind of from the first take.
One of my favorite scenes is when Angela screams and smashes the glass ornaments. What was it like to film? All of that. Yes, exactly. But now if you go back and watch the scene, you guys, watch the first two that I throw. I think that's kind of from the first take.|||我最喜欢的场景之一就是安吉拉尖叫并砸碎玻璃装饰品的时候。拍摄时是什么感觉？就是那样。是的，没错。但现在如果你们回去重看那场戏，大家注意看我扔的前两个。我觉得那差不多是第一条拍的。
They bounce straight up. So when we go back up in the office, I have to point out that when everybody decides to go to poor Richards, Michael gets invited and the look on his face, it's better than any gift he could have been given. I know. And this is that moment where you're like, Michael has been just such a jerk this whole episode.
They bounce straight up. So when we go back up in the office, I have to point out that when everybody decides to go to poor Richards, Michael gets invited and the look on his face, it's better than any gift he could have been given. I know. And this is that moment where you're like, Michael has been just such a jerk this whole episode.|||它们直接弹了起来。所以当我们回到办公室时，我必须指出，当大家决定去Poor Richard酒吧时，迈克尔受到了邀请，他脸上的表情，比他可能收到的任何礼物都好。我知道。这就是那种让你觉得，迈克尔整集都表现得像个混蛋的时刻。
And then you see this sort of sad wounded person that just wants people to like him. Yes. How much he needs people to invite him to have drinks. Like he needs it. Or he needs his gift to be the most popular. Yeah. He needs that acceptance. Well, we have Michael's talking head at the end
And then you see this sort of sad wounded person that just wants people to like him. Yes. How much he needs people to invite him to have drinks. Like he needs it. Or he needs his gift to be the most popular. Yeah. He needs that acceptance. Well, we have Michael's talking head at the end|||然后你会看到这种悲伤受伤的人，他只是想让别人喜欢他。是的。他多么需要别人邀请他去喝一杯。就像他需要这个一样。或者他需要他的礼物是最受欢迎的。是的。他需要那种认同。好吧，我们来看看最后迈克尔的访谈
where he's talking about Christmas and gifts. Here's a little fun tidbit. This talking head was originally shot to be at the beginning of the episode. Oh, but when they were editing, they put it at the end because Greg wanted to do kind of a montage of scenes and of people leaving of us out in the snow and the parking lot.
where he's talking about Christmas and gifts. Here's a little fun tidbit. This talking head was originally shot to be at the beginning of the episode. Oh, but when they were editing, they put it at the end because Greg wanted to do kind of a montage of scenes and of people leaving of us out in the snow and the parking lot.|||他在谈论圣诞节和礼物。这里有个有趣的冷知识。这段访谈最初拍摄时是放在剧集开头。哦，但在剪辑时，他们把它放到了最后，因为格雷格想做一段蒙太奇，包括各种场景、人们离开、我们站在雪地和停车场里的画面。
And he was like, oh, wait, that talking head, that works perfectly. Because something that we couldn't do because the documentary style, you couldn't do a montage with a song. No, you had montages were set to talking heads. And we have had a montage with song, but it's like the song playing in the car.
And he was like, oh, wait, that talking head, that works perfectly. Because something that we couldn't do because the documentary style, you couldn't do a montage with a song. No, you had montages were set to talking heads. And we have had a montage with song, but it's like the song playing in the car.|||然后他说，哦，等等，那个访谈，放在这太完美了。因为有些事情我们不能做，由于纪录片风格，你不能用一首歌来做蒙太奇。不，你们的蒙太奇都是配上访谈。我们确实有过配歌的蒙太奇，但那就像是在车里放歌一样。
Sure. Something like that. It has to be sound that is, what do they call that? Like a live sound. A live sound. Yeah, something like that. Active sound. Yeah.
Sure. Something like that. It has to be sound that is, what do they call that? Like a live sound. A live sound. Yeah, something like that. Active sound. Yeah.|||当然。差不多吧。那必须是那种声音，他们叫什么来着？就像现场音。现场音。对，类似这样的。活动音。对。
Before we get to the final scenes of the show, I just wanted to point out two lines that fans have quoted as some of their favorite lines ever in this episode. Oh, yes. Say them. One is happy birthday, Jesus. Sorry, your party is so lame. Yes. And another fan favorite is Yankee Swap
Before we get to the final scenes of the show, I just wanted to point out two lines that fans have quoted as some of their favorite lines ever in this episode. Oh, yes. Say them. One is happy birthday, Jesus. Sorry, your party is so lame. Yes. And another fan favorite is Yankee Swap|||在我们进入节目的最后几个场景之前，我只想指出粉丝们引用过的两句台词，他们认为是这一集中最喜欢的台词之一。哦，是的。说出来听听。一个是“耶鲁生日快乐，对不起，你的派对太逊了。”是的。另一个粉丝最爱的是“扬基交换礼物”
is like Machiavelli meets Christmas. And I really do want you guys to check out the DVD deleted scenes from this episode. By the way, we're not getting paid to say that. We're not. We just really think they're good. We just really think they're good. And you guys, Oscar Nunez is so great with physical comedy.
is like Machiavelli meets Christmas. And I really do want you guys to check out the DVD deleted scenes from this episode. By the way, we're not getting paid to say that. We're not. We just really think they're good. We just really think they're good. And you guys, Oscar Nunez is so great with physical comedy.|||就像“马基雅维利遇到圣诞节”。我真的很想让大家去看这一集的DVD删减片段。顺便说一句，我们说这个可没拿钱。真没有。我们只是真的觉得它们很好。我们只是真的觉得它们很好。还有各位，奥斯卡·努涅斯在肢体喜剧方面太棒了。
I did a sketch show with him before the office years ago in my 20s. We've known each other forever. He is a great physical comedian, but he didn't get to do very much of that on the office. But there is a scene in the deleted scenes where him and Creed move a desk
I did a sketch show with him before the office years ago in my 20s. We've known each other forever. He is a great physical comedian, but he didn't get to do very much of that on the office. But there is a scene in the deleted scenes where him and Creed move a desk|||多年前在我二十多岁拍《办公室》之前，我和他一起演过小品秀。我们认识很久了。他是个很棒的肢体喜剧演员，但他在《办公室》里没怎么展现这一点。但在删减片段里有一个场景，他和克里德搬一张桌子
and he gets pinned in by the desk. And he has to get out from being stuck. And it's really, really funny. I want to see that. And Phyllis reveals in a deleted scene for this episode how she met Bob. She says that they met because he works next door. So there you go.
and he gets pinned in by the desk. And he has to get out from being stuck. And it's really, really funny. I want to see that. And Phyllis reveals in a deleted scene for this episode how she met Bob. She says that they met because he works next door. So there you go.|||然后他被桌子夹住了。他必须从卡住的状态中挣脱出来。真的非常非常搞笑。我想看那个。菲利丝在这一集的删减片段中透露了她是如何遇到鲍勃的。她说他们相遇是因为他在隔壁上班。就是这样。
They were right there together. And Kevin has a whole rap. He raps. Oh, a whole portion of a song. So really check out these deleted scenes if you can. They're fantastic. All right, let's talk about the final scene inside the office. All right, it happens in Michael's office.
They were right there together. And Kevin has a whole rap. He raps. Oh, a whole portion of a song. So really check out these deleted scenes if you can. They're fantastic. All right, let's talk about the final scene inside the office. All right, it happens in Michael's office.|||他们就在那里一起工作。凯文还有整段说唱。他唱歌。哦，整整一段歌。所以如果可以的话，一定要去看看这些删减片段。它们太棒了。好了，我们来聊聊办公室里面的最后一个场景。好吧，它发生在迈克尔的办公室里。
He's getting ready to leave. He's going to go downstairs. Meredith just walks into his office, takes off her top, and then Steve as Michael takes a picture and then walks out. I have a fan question. Well, first of all, Kate, I really wanted Kate to be able to call in for this one.
He's getting ready to leave. He's going to go downstairs. Meredith just walks into his office, takes off her top, and then Steve as Michael takes a picture and then walks out. I have a fan question. Well, first of all, Kate, I really wanted Kate to be able to call in for this one.|||他正准备离开。他要下楼去。梅雷迪思走进了他的办公室，脱掉了上衣，然后史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔拍了张照片，然后走了出去。我有一个粉丝提问。嗯，首先，凯特，我真的很希望凯特能为这一期打个电话进来。
I traded texts with her, but she is starting a tour with Dancing with the Stars. Oh, yeah. And she's traveling today. She's on a plane and she called me night before last. And she was like, and I'm so sorry I can't come in. But she was like, I really do want to come in
I traded texts with her, but she is starting a tour with Dancing with the Stars. Oh, yeah. And she's traveling today. She's on a plane and she called me night before last. And she was like, and I'm so sorry I can't come in. But she was like, I really do want to come in|||我和她发过短信，但她要开始参加《与星共舞》的巡演了。哦，对。她今天在赶路。她在飞机上，前天晚上给我打了个电话。她说，非常抱歉我没法参加。但她说，我真的很想来
and talk about all things Meredith. So she will come eventually. Oh, that's good. I have a feeling you might know the answer to this fan question. OK. OK, Carrie Shab said, or maybe it's Carrie Shabe, said, when characters flash each other,
and talk about all things Meredith. So she will come eventually. Oh, that's good. I have a feeling you might know the answer to this fan question. OK. OK, Carrie Shab said, or maybe it's Carrie Shabe, said, when characters flash each other,|||聊聊关于梅雷迪思的一切。所以她最终会来的。哦，那很好。我有种感觉，你可能知道这个粉丝问题的答案。好的。好的，凯莉·沙布说，或者可能是凯莉·沙贝，说，当角色们向彼此展示身体时，
are the actors really flashing each other in real life? No, no, no. No. No. I mean, sort of. Sort of. But no. I mean, it's still embarrassing.
are the actors really flashing each other in real life? No, no, no. No. No. I mean, sort of. Sort of. But no. I mean, it's still embarrassing.|||演员们在现实生活中真的互相赤诚相见吗？不，不，不。不。不。我的意思是，算是吧。算是吧。但也不是。我的意思是，这还是很尴尬。
Even if I had to like be in a bathing suit, I'd feel awkward. You know what I mean? Kate was wearing pasties. Kate had things. She was kind of covered. Yeah. She had things over her hoo-has.
Even if I had to like be in a bathing suit, I'd feel awkward. You know what I mean? Kate was wearing pasties. Kate had things. She was kind of covered. Yeah. She had things over her hoo-has.|||就算我得穿泳衣之类的，我也会觉得尴尬。你知道我的意思吗？凯特当时贴了胸贴。凯特带了道具。她基本上遮住了。是的。她的私处有遮挡物。
Yeah. Steve is such a gentleman. He said, Kate, I'm just going to look at like your neck. Yeah. I stare at your clavicle. They had no crew inside. Yep. Her image wasn't on any monitors anywhere.
Yeah. Steve is such a gentleman. He said, Kate, I'm just going to look at like your neck. Yeah. I stare at your clavicle. They had no crew inside. Yep. Her image wasn't on any monitors anywhere.|||对。史蒂夫真是个绅士。他说，凯特，我只会看你的脖子。对。我盯着你的锁骨看。里面没有剧组人员。是的。她的影像没有显示在任何监视器上。
That's right. And there was no chip in the digital camera. So the flash goes off. It looks like Michael's taking a picture, but there was actually never a picture taken. Never a photo. So they were very, very mindful of taking care of Kate in that moment.
That's right. And there was no chip in the digital camera. So the flash goes off. It looks like Michael's taking a picture, but there was actually never a picture taken. Never a photo. So they were very, very mindful of taking care of Kate in that moment.|||没错。数码相机里也没有内存卡。所以闪光灯亮了。看起来迈克尔在拍照，但实际上根本没拍下照片。一张照片都没有。所以他们在那个时刻非常非常注意照顾凯特。
Kate would go on as Meredith to take off her clothes and quite a bit. Quite a bit. One of my favorite things is that Kate's father wrote her a handwritten letter. Oh, my goodness. And all it said, this is her father who, you know, Kate is from Pennsylvania.
Kate would go on as Meredith to take off her clothes and quite a bit. Quite a bit. One of my favorite things is that Kate's father wrote her a handwritten letter. Oh, my goodness. And all it said, this is her father who, you know, Kate is from Pennsylvania.|||凯特后来作为梅雷迪思脱衣服的次数还挺多的。相当多。我最喜欢的事情之一就是凯特的父亲给她写了一封手写信。哦，我的天哪。信上写着，这是她的父亲，你知道，凯特来自宾夕法尼亚州。
And all it said was, dear Kate, stop taking your clothes off. Love, dad. Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh. What did Kate do? How did she respond to that? She was like, oh, man. Now, is that her dad having a sense of humor?
And all it said was, dear Kate, stop taking your clothes off. Love, dad. Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh. What did Kate do? How did she respond to that? She was like, oh, man. Now, is that her dad having a sense of humor?|||上面只写着：亲爱的凯特，别再脱衣服了。爱你的爸爸。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。凯特做了什么？她是怎么回应的？她的反应是，天哪。话说回来，这是她爸爸很有幽默感呢？
Or is that him being like, seriously, stop it? I think both. I think both. All right. Should we talk about the parking lot? We're almost done here. Yes. Let's talk about the parking lot because it is definitely
Or is that him being like, seriously, stop it? I think both. I think both. All right. Should we talk about the parking lot? We're almost done here. Yes. Let's talk about the parking lot because it is definitely|||还是他认真的在说“说真的，别脱了”？我觉得两者都有。我觉得两者都有。好了。我们该聊聊停车场了吗？我们这快结束了。是的。我们来聊聊停车场，因为它绝对是
one of the most magical moments that I remember in filming all nine years. And we all say that. Yeah. People often ask, like, what were your favorite scenes? And it's always hard to explain because sometimes your favorite scene, it doesn't seem like that exciting of a scene, but it's what happened behind the scenes
one of the most magical moments that I remember in filming all nine years. And we all say that. Yeah. People often ask, like, what were your favorite scenes? And it's always hard to explain because sometimes your favorite scene, it doesn't seem like that exciting of a scene, but it's what happened behind the scenes|||我拍摄整整九年里记忆中最神奇的时刻之一。我们大家都这么说。是的。人们经常问，你们最喜欢的场景是什么？这总是很难解释，因为有时候你最喜欢的场景，看起来并没有那么激动人心，但幕后发生的事
that make it your favorite. And this parking lot scene is one of mine. Definitely. Definitely. OK, so it's the end of the day. We have all of this real snow on the ground. And everyone is leaving. And everyone's in good spirits.
that make it your favorite. And this parking lot scene is one of mine. Definitely. Definitely. OK, so it's the end of the day. We have all of this real snow on the ground. And everyone is leaving. And everyone's in good spirits.|||才让它成了你的最爱。这个停车场场景就是我的最爱之一。绝对是的。绝对是的。好的，到了今天收工的时候。地上全都是真正的雪。每个人都在离开。每个人都兴致勃勃。
And it's really nighttime. It was rare for us to ever work past 6 p.m. So we always got excited to walk out in the dark, I think. We all felt like we were up past our bedtime. But also, you have to remember, this is Los Angeles. There's never snow on the ground. So this is magical in itself, that we have a parking lot full of snow.
And it's really nighttime. It was rare for us to ever work past 6 p.m. So we always got excited to walk out in the dark, I think. We all felt like we were up past our bedtime. But also, you have to remember, this is Los Angeles. There's never snow on the ground. So this is magical in itself, that we have a parking lot full of snow.|||而且真的是晚上了。我们很少工作到下午6点以后。所以我猜，每次能走在黑夜里我们都会很兴奋。我们都觉得自己熬夜了。而且，你必须记住，这里是洛杉矶。地上从来不下雪。所以这本身就很神奇，我们的停车场积满了雪。
And as we're walking to the cars, I don't know. Like, the shot you see, I'm actually in the front passenger seat of an SUV, but I'm only half in. Like, the door's open. But I remember one of the guys just picked up some snow and flung it at the other one. And then they all started picking up snow and having this impromptu snowball fight.
And as we're walking to the cars, I don't know. Like, the shot you see, I'm actually in the front passenger seat of an SUV, but I'm only half in. Like, the door's open. But I remember one of the guys just picked up some snow and flung it at the other one. And then they all started picking up snow and having this impromptu snowball fight.|||当我们走向汽车时，我不知道。就像你看到的镜头，我其实在一辆SUV的前排乘客座里，但我只有半个身子在里面。车门是开着的。但我记得其中一个人抓起一把雪，朝另一个人砸过去。然后他们所有人开始抓起雪，打起了这场即兴的雪仗。
Yeah. And everyone loved it. And they wanted us to keep doing it. But it was just sort of like us just all hanging out in the snow. Yeah. And we turned into a bunch of kids. We couldn't help it.
Yeah. And everyone loved it. And they wanted us to keep doing it. But it was just sort of like us just all hanging out in the snow. Yeah. And we turned into a bunch of kids. We couldn't help it.|||是的。每个人都很喜欢。他们希望我们继续打下去。但这更像是我们所有人一起在雪地里玩耍。是的。我们变成了一群孩子。我们控制不住自己。
Yeah. We were up past our bedtime with snow on the ground. Fresh snow on the ground. It was so fun. And you know, I have a picture of all of us together in the parking lot with Charles McDougal. And it's great. I love it.
Yeah. We were up past our bedtime with snow on the ground. Fresh snow on the ground. It was so fun. And you know, I have a picture of all of us together in the parking lot with Charles McDougal. And it's great. I love it.|||对。我们踩着地上的雪熬夜了。地上积着新雪。太有趣了。你知道吗，我有一张我们所有人一起在停车场里和查尔斯·麦克杜格尔的合照。太棒了。我很喜欢。
I covet it. I love that. I want to see it. Yeah. Well, this is why we have to make our scrapbook thingy, Angela. We do. We should combine. Well, that's what we need to do.
I covet it. I love that. I want to see it. Yeah. Well, this is why we have to make our scrapbook thingy, Angela. We do. We should combine. Well, that's what we need to do.|||我好嫉妒。我很喜欢那个。我想看。是的。所以这就是为什么我们得做我们的剪贴簿，安吉拉。我们得做。我们应该合起来。好吧，这就是我们要做的。
We need to compile and combine all our stuff. All of our photos. And then make it so that we can both have what we both have. Yeah. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Before we lose it all, we need to do it.
We need to compile and combine all our stuff. All of our photos. And then make it so that we can both have what we both have. Yeah. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Before we lose it all, we need to do it.|||我们需要搜集并结合我们所有的东西。我们所有的照片。然后做成这样，我们两个都能拥有彼此拥有的东西。是的。对吧？是的。是的。在我们把它们都弄丢之前，我们得把这事做了。
OK. It's 2020. We need to do this. We need to do this. This is a goal for this year. I'm setting the goal for us this year. Well, you guys, she said it. Now I've got, like, Jenna's going to put me to task. This episode was really special.
OK. It's 2020. We need to do this. We need to do this. This is a goal for this year. I'm setting the goal for us this year. Well, you guys, she said it. Now I've got, like, Jenna's going to put me to task. This episode was really special.|||好吧。现在是2020年。我们得把这事做了。我们得把这事做了。这是今年的目标。我为我们定下了今年的目标。好吧，各位，她话都说出口了。现在我得……詹娜要来监督我了。这一集真的很特别。
It was. I really hope we did it, Justice, because it means so much to us. These episodes are almost harder for me than other ones because there's so much emotion attached to it. There's so much that happens in the scene. Not only, like, is it special to us personally, but it was like a big moment for our characters.
It was. I really hope we did it, Justice, because it means so much to us. These episodes are almost harder for me than other ones because there's so much emotion attached to it. There's so much that happens in the scene. Not only, like, is it special to us personally, but it was like a big moment for our characters.|||确实很特别。我真的希望我们没有辜负它，因为它对我们意义重大。对我来说，这些剧集甚至比其他剧集更难，因为里面包含了太多的情感。场景中发生了太多事。不仅对我们个人来说很特殊，而且对我们的角色来说也是一个重大的时刻。
Yeah. And just that moment at the end, that snowball fight, that is just a group of people who love each other, who are all getting to hang out, and we just happen to be on a TV show together. Yeah. It's just a really special moment. And I love that they let that be how it ended.
Yeah. And just that moment at the end, that snowball fight, that is just a group of people who love each other, who are all getting to hang out, and we just happen to be on a TV show together. Yeah. It's just a really special moment. And I love that they let that be how it ended.|||是的。还有最后那个时刻，那场雪仗，那正是一群彼此相爱的人聚在一起玩耍，而我们刚好一起拍了一部电视剧。是的。这真的是一个非常特别的时刻。我很喜欢他们让它以这种方式结束。
And that's really how it felt when we left this show, that we were just a bunch of friends who happened to be on a TV show together, because we were friends. And we are friends. Yeah. And we're family. We are.
And that's really how it felt when we left this show, that we were just a bunch of friends who happened to be on a TV show together, because we were friends. And we are friends. Yeah. And we're family. We are.|||这真的就是我们离开这部剧时的感受，我们只是一群恰好一起拍了一部电视剧的朋友，因为我们本来就是朋友。我们就是朋友。是的。我们是一家人。我们确实是。
So next week, we've got another big episode, Ann. Huge episode. I mean, listen, the rest of this season, too, is just going to be one momentous episode after the other. Next up is Booze Cruise with our special guest, Creator of the American Office, Greg Daniels. Greg Daniels is going to be here. We are super excited.
So next week, we've got another big episode, Ann. Huge episode. I mean, listen, the rest of this season, too, is just going to be one momentous episode after the other. Next up is Booze Cruise with our special guest, Creator of the American Office, Greg Daniels. Greg Daniels is going to be here. We are super excited.|||所以下周，我们还有另一个重头戏，安。超级重头戏。我是说，听着，接下来这一季的剩余剧集，也将会是一集比一集重大。接下来是《酒类游轮》，我们的特邀嘉宾是美国版《办公室》的创作者格雷格·丹尼尔斯。格雷格·丹尼尔斯要来这里。我们超级兴奋。
Yeah. We cannot wait to talk to him. Thank you, Greg, in advance. And Booze Cruise is a huge, huge episode. We'll see you next week. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf,
Yeah. We cannot wait to talk to him. Thank you, Greg, in advance. And Booze Cruise is a huge, huge episode. We'll see you next week. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf,|||是的。我们迫不及待地想跟他聊聊。提前谢谢你，格雷格。《酒类游轮》是一集非常非常重磅的剧集。我们下周见。拜拜。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf制作，
Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episode's candy bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium,
Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episode's candy bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium,|||詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版的节目以及我们番外篇的彩蛋包，请访问StitcherPremium.com。免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，
use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.|||请使用优惠码Office。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。